mes chers collègues on va on va essayer
de d'être
rapide sans se précipiter pour longtemps
mais concis parce que je sais qu'il y a
un certain nombre de
collègues qui ont prévu de repartir ce
soir contre tenue que peut-être demain
tout ne fonctionnera pas correctement
moi j'ai le temps moi j'ai le temps moi
je reporte pas avant la fin de la
semaine donc si ça dure toute la nuit
moi ça me pose aucun problème mais c'est
simplement pour aider quelques collègues
qui m'ont dit qu'il prenaient des trains
ce soir voilà je ne fais que le relais
de certains collègues et madame la
secrétaire d'État mes chers collègues
après entendu ce matin l'ambassadrice
délégué à l'environnement sur les enjeux
de la COP15 nous poursuivons cette
journée placé sous les hospices de la
biodiversité et de l'environnement le
grand plaisir d'accueillir la secrétaire
d'État chargé d'écologie
pour sa première intervention devant
notre commission vos attributions ont
été précisées par des crayons date du 29
juillet dernier et le constat qui
s'impose dans le parcourant c'est que
votre secrétariat d'État et notre
commission sont unis par une grande
proximité avec des champs de compétences
très proches afin que nos collègues
puissent s'en rendre compte je les ai
minerai brièvement protection et
valorisation de la nature et de la
biodiversité
transition vers une économie circulaire
politique de réduction et de traitement
des déchets
négociation européenne et internationale
sur l'eau et la biodiversité
gestion de la faune sauvage et des
grands prédateurs protection des
paysages et des sites pilotage et
coordination de la Stratégie nationale
pour la biodiversité
pour chacun des items de votre
portefeuille ministériel est offé vous
avez face à vous plusieurs commissaires
spécialisés qui ne manquent pas de vous
interroger sur votre feuille de route et
sur les priorités que vous comptez
porter
mais également aux côtés des territoires
et au niveau ministériel vous le savez
nous avons au Sénat la conviction que
c'est que ce sont les collectivités
territoriales
et avec les collectivités territoriales
que nous réussirons la transition
écologique en les accompagnant et en les
mettant au centre du jeu en premier lieu
j'aimerais connaître l'esprit et les
ambitions qui vous animent à un mois de
la COP15 à laquelle vous participerez
avec vos équipes
comment mesdames la ministre
préparez-vous cette échéance primordiale
pour élaborer un nouveau cadre mondial
pour la biodiversité à l'horizon 2030
quelles sont les enseignements que l'on
peut d'ores et déjà tirer des
négociations préalables et des échanges
informels qui ont eu lieu en amont de la
COP15 alors que la France qu'au
président avec le Costa Rica la
coalition de la haute ambition pour la
nature et les peuples un accord
ambitieux et transformateur est-il à
notre portée
elle se propose je vous informe qu'une
délégation de notre commission se rendra
à Montréal du 11 au 14 décembre prochain
pour contribuer modestement à faire
entendre la voix de la France sur les
sujets sujets qui nous sont chers vous
pourrez compter sur notre appui et notre
soutien lors de cet échéance décisive
période budgétaire oblique nous
aimerions également que vous évoquiez
les priorités que vous évoquiez les
évolutions des crédits consacrées à
l'environnement à l'occasion du projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 en cours
d'examen
nous ne réjouissons que le budget de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires soit porté à 40
milliards d'euros mais force est de
constater que le bouclier est tarifaire
sur le gaz électricité contribue
grandement au brunissement du budget de
l'État et à la moindrement des efforts
de la France comme le montre le rapport
sur l'impact environnemental du budget
de l'État la crise énergétique que nous
subissons montre à quel point la
transition climatique et écologique et
dépendante des facteurs sociaux
économiques
la forte inflation subie par les
opérateurs l'évolution du coût de
l'énergie et la revalorisation du point
d'indice invite en partie à relativiser
l'importance des augmentations qui
figurent dans la mission écologique
développement et mobilité durable les
opérateurs entendus par nos rapporteurs
pour avis font état de surcoût important
lié à la consommation de fluides qui
dépasse souvent les hausses de crédit
qui leur ont été octroyées comment
madame la ministre le gouvernement
compte-t-il accompagné des opérateurs à
qui l'on demande toujours plus si
l'inflation devait durablement
s'installer j'aimerais enfin vous
interroger sur le fond vert doté
initialement de 1,5 milliards d'euros
puis de 2 milliards afin d'accélérer la
planification écologique territoriale
pouvez-vous nous préciser les actions
subventionnelles qui entrent dans le
champ de cette nouvelle enveloppe selon
quel mécanisme et critère seront-ils
répartis
comment les collectivités territoriales
pourront-elles en bénéficier
y a-t-il une clé de répartition
géographique comment le dialogue avec
les préfets et les maires concernant
l'articulation des crédits sera-t-il
assuré
sur la somme totale à l'eau au fond vert
quelle est la part des crédits recyclés
et des crédits nouveaux
maintenant le secrétaire d'État vous
avez la parole pour un propos liminaire
synthétique et je voulais et je vous
laisserai répondre à cette série de
questions avant de répondre à la
séquence des questions réponses de mes
collègues je vous souhaite la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je tenais déjà
un premiere chose à vous remercier pour
votre invitation parce que j'ai beaucoup
de plaisir à venir dans cet enceinte et
de pouvoir évidemment avoir un dialogue
constructif avec vous voilà donc je suis
évidemment ravie de cette invitation et
donc je renouvelle mes remerciements
l'été que que nous venons de traverser
entre pénurie d'eau et incendie a été
une nouvelle illustration de l'urgence
écologique à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés le changement climatique a
désormais un impact concret sur tous les
pans de notre vie quotidienne que plus
personne ne peut nier mais l'urgence
elle est également celle de la
préservation de la nature en 50 ans la
situation de nos espaces naturels de nos
océans comme de la faune mondiale et
devenu extrêmement alarmante
perte de 35% des lacs rivières et marais
disparition de 66% des mammifères perte
de 80% des poissons d'eau douce un
million d'espèces sont aujourd'hui
menacés ce qui est inédit dans notre
histoire le portefeuille qui m'a été
confié à cette vocation mettre la
préservation de la biodiversité au même
niveau que le climat cette extinction
silencieuse qui se déroule sous nos yeux
doit être combattue avec la plus grande
force elle constitue avec la lutte
contre le changement climatique une
priorité absolue du mandat du Président
de la République qui a nommé pour la
première fois une première ministre en
charge de la planification écologique
son pilotage s'appuie sur des moyens
nouveaux et conséquents
comme vous le savez la première ministre
a annoncée donc un fond un fond
d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires de 2
milliards d'euros dont au minimum 150
millions d'euros pour la biodiversité il
s'agit bien de crédits nouveaux tous
orienter vers l'adaptation de nos
territoires aux enjeux du changement
climatique et la lutte contre l'érosion
de la biodiversité le budget que je
viens vous présenter aujourd'hui et donc
bien un budget de cohérence entre
l'ambition que nous portons et les
moyens que nous donnons
pour 2023 la préservation de la
biodiversité et la prévention des
risques bénéficieront de 3,6 milliards
d'euros
la troisième stratégie nationale
biodiversité qui est en cours
d'achèvement doit être la référence
cadre pour la mobilisation de nos
énergies
150 millions d'euros lui seront
spécifiquement dédiés dans le cadre du
fond d'accélération de la transition
écologique
le premier objectif de mon portefeuille
est donc bien la protection des espaces
naturels et des habitats
c'est ce que je porte avec la stratégie
nationale Air protégée qui a été
inscrite dans la loi climat et
résilience elle a fixé deux cibles
majeures que vous connaissez déjà
protégez 30% de notre territoire dont un
tiers en protection forte ces cibles
concernent l'Hexagone comme l'autre Mère
la Terre autant que la mer
aujourd'hui si l'objectif de protection
est atteint il reste encore du chemin à
parcourir en matière de protection forte
de nouveaux projets sont en cours de
réflexion localement et nous n'écartons
pas la possibilité d'un onzième parc
national sur les zones humides
sur cette question de la protection je
travaille à l'aboutissement du transfert
aux régions des sites Natura 2000 décidé
par la loi 3DS le dialogue se poursuit
avec région de France
aussi la protection des espaces et les
habitats doit nous permettre de mieux
appréhender la seconde priorité qui est
la protection du vivant
je le disais en introduction l'érosion
de la biodiversité animale et tout aussi
inquiétante que celle de nos espaces
naturels les plans nationaux d'action
constituent un autre outil majeur qui
vient en complément du régime de
protection légale des espèces cette
plans nationaux de préservation d'espace
d'espèces menacées dans l'Hexagone comme
en outre-mer ont été lancé dernièrement
je suis aussi régulièrement interpellé
au sujet des prédateurs la grande la
première chose que je souhaite dire et
mon soutien à tous nos éleveurs je
consulte tous les acteurs sans
exclusivité pour connaître les visions
de chacun et voir comment avancer dans
la résolution de ces conflits les
espèces sont protégées il s'agit donc
d'accompagner l'augmentation des
populations vers des populations viables
en gérant au mieux les dommages sur les
élevages
l'eau est le troisième grand pan de
cette lutte pour la préservation de la
biodiversité c'est pour répondre à ces
tensions sur l'eau que nous avons lancé
avec Christophe Béchu et Agnès Firmin
lobaudeau un grand chantier haut à
Marseille le 29 septembre dernier nous
devons rapidement apprendre à concilier
solution de cours et de long terme
principal financeur de la biodiversité
en France les agences de l'eau
bénéficient d'un plafond annuel de
recettes pour des redevances qui est
fixé à 2,2 milliards d'euros depuis la
loi de finances 2021 ce plafond est
maintenu tout comme leur plafond
d'emploi pour 2023
de l'érosion du trait de côte
et tous également un sujet que vous
connaissez bien et qui pèse fortement
sur les collectivités territoriales il
est également au cœur de mon
portefeuille sur ce sujet j'ai
conscience de la nécessité de construire
une capacité pérenne de financement des
adaptations qui seront nécessaires dans
les prochaines années nous estimons à 20
millions d'euros le besoin de
financement annuel pour répondre aux
enjeux nous avons conscience que
certaines années peuvent nécessiter plus
et d'autres moins ce sont justement plus
de 20 millions d'euros qui seront
engagés en 2023 dans le cadre du projet
loi de finance toutefois nous devrons
parvenir à trouver un mode de
financement pérenne qui ne repose ni
uniquement sur les collectivités
territoriales ni uniquement sur l'état
je vais donc lancer une grande
consultation avec les parlementaires et
les élus locaux d'une durée d'un an pour
parvenir à élaborer ensemble ce modèle
de financement
je partage également l'enjeu de la
protection et d'une utilisation durable
de nos forêts avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture 200 millions d'euros
seront consacrés à l'adaptation des
forêts au changement climatiques
s'agissant du renouvellement forestier
il est envisagé un financement pérenne
de 100 à 150 millions d'euros par an
mobilisant les outils de la finance
carbone dans le même temps un chantier
national de replantation des forêts va
être lancée avec l'objectif de replanter
un milliard d'arbres d'ici 10 ans ça a
été annoncé par le président de la
République la semaine dernière
plus globalement la première ministre a
annoncé que le que la forêt serait un
des premiers secteurs concernés par la
planification écologique dans cette
perspective je souhaite avec les acquis
des Assises de la forêt
c'est que ça servent de socle pour
prolonger et amplifier les actions
je suis aussi concerné par la question
de la chasse
les accidents sont une préoccupation
majeure si des progrès ont été réalisés
depuis 20 ans avec une baisse sensible
du nombre d'accidents nous devons tendre
vers le zéro accident
comme vous le savez évidemment les
sénateurs chaises et Carrère on produit
un rapport dont je souhaite saluer la
qualité il sera l'une des bases de la
réflexion globale que je souhaite lancer
sur ce sujet cette consultation devra
permettre de trouver des solutions qui
portent sur l'ensemble des enjeux la
formation
l'encadrement des pratiques de la chasse
l'information et le partage de l'espace
et je souhaite aboutir d'ici Noël sur ce
dossier
les moyens du ministère sont concentrés
sur le programme 113 paysages hauts et
biodiversité que vous aurez évidemment à
voter prochainement dans le cadre de
l'examen de la deuxième partie du PLF il
connaît une nouvelle augmentation de
30,4 millions d'euros par rapport à 2022
et va atteindre 274 millions d'euros en
l'Office français de la biodiversité qui
est sous la tutelle du ministère de la
transition écologique verra sa
subvention pour charge de service public
de l'ofb augmenté de 25 millions d'euros
à format constant elle atteindra donc
78,8 millions d'euros et s'ajoutera à la
contribution de près de 383 millions
d'euros des agences de l'eau pour 2023
second opérateur particulièrement
important pour les parlementaires
l'Office National des Forêts
principalement sous tutelle du ministère
de l'Agriculture il bénéficiera d'une
augmentation pour ses missions d'intérêt
général de 2,5 millions d'euros auquel
s'ajoute 10 millions d'Euros pour
renforcer les missions des SCI
enfin nous pouvons noter que 5tp
supplémentaires ont été accordées aux
Conservatoire du littoral il viendront
soutenir sa politique d'extension des
territoires qu'il protège
je vais vous parler maintenant
d'économie circulaire nous devons tendre
vers une société de la réparation du
réemploi et du recyclage pour économiser
nos ressources et des carbonner notre
consommation aujourd'hui les
financements de l'économie circulaire
sont supportés d'une part par les
filières à responsabilité élargie des
producteurs les reps et d'autre part par
la dame qui est l'opérateur de l'État
dans ce domaine l'ADEME bénéficiera de
crédit du programme 181 pour le fond
économie circulaire qui est revalorisé à
220 millions d'euros pour 2023
ces moyens financiers doivent répondre à
un objectif clair état collectivité
producteur et consommateurs doivent
réduire les quantités de déchets mis en
décharge et développer le recyclage
particulièrement des plastiques ainsi
que la valorisation des biodéchets pour
parvenir à cet objectif d'une meilleure
gestion de nos déchets une trajectoire
de hausse de la taxe générale sur les
activités polluantes la TGAP sur
l'enfouissement des déchets a été
programmé entre 2018 et 2025
elle doit donner de la visibilité et
rendent le recyclage des déchets
économiquement plus attractif que leur
élimination cette réforme s'inscrit dans
un équilibre global dans lequel de
nouvelles capacités financières ont été
données aux collectivités pour investir
et pour s'adapter à travers plusieurs
mécanismes de soutien comme l'allnement
à 5,5% de la TVA sur les activités de
tri de recyclage et de prévention des
déchets la réduction des frais de
gestion perçus par l'État sur la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
incitatives également la mise en place
de nouvelles filières à responsabilité
élargie des producteurs dit très
au delà des mesures de réduction des
déchets la politique de l'économie
circulaire que nous menons réoriente la
prise en charge des déchets de plus en
plus fortement vers les fabricants et
distributeurs des produits dans une
logique de pollueurs
d'ici 2030 ce sont 6 milliards d'euros
que représenteront l'ensemble de ces
filières reps pour réduire les coûts de
la réparation des produits cela doit
permettre d'augmenter leur durée de vie
de développer le réemploi et produire et
les produits pardon reconditionnés et de
recycler les déchets
une nouvelle règle pour les produits et
matériaux de construction du bâtiment
par exemple été lancé en octobre ce sont
ainsi quatre éco-organismes que l'on
vient d'intégrer d'agréer aussi pour une
entrée en vigueur entre 2023 et 2027
l'objectif est de développer dès 2023 le
réemploi et le recyclage des déchets du
bâtiment mais aussi de mettre fin aux
décharge sauvage grâce à la reprise
gratuite des déchets et la création de
nouvelles déchetteries accessibles aux
artisans et TPE
parmi les secteurs dans lesquels nous
devons accélérer le secteur du textile
est l'un des plus impactants le textile
représente 450 000 tonnes jetés dans les
poubelles chaque année ça représente
tout de même 45 tours Eiffel
l'empreinte carbone de notre
consommation textile est de près de 30
millions de tonnes équivalent carbone
c'est pour répondre à ces défis que j'ai
lancé début octobre une grande
consultation pour transformer en six ans
la filière textile afin de financer la
réparation le réemploi et le
développement d'une filière industrielle
de recyclage des textiles en France
c'est une rêve qui peut atteindre 600
millions d'euros sur la période pour
favoriser la réparation le réemploi le
recyclage et 350 millions pour avantager
via des bonus les produits éco-conçus
nous agissons aussi sur les emballages
ménagers parmi les nouveaux financements
on compte 62 millions d'euros pour les
nouvelles poubelles de rue et 100
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
collectivités dans le nettoyage des
espaces publics
sur le plastique toute repondu 4
millions de tonnes sont jetés chaque
année en majorité des emballages le
recyclage de tous les plastiques reste
insuffisants et à peine 20% à ce jour
sont recyclés nous pouvons et je crois
pouvoir dire que nous devons faire mieux
certaines solutions qui ont pu être
écartées dans un passé récent sont
désormais assez mûres pour être
réabordés je pense par exemple à la
consigne la loi AGEC a fixé un
calendrier clair une décision doit être
prise en juin 2023
si je dis bien si nous avons à décider
d'une consigne en juin prochain je veux
traiter au préalable tous les enjeux que
je rappellerai précédemment
que je rappelais pardon précédemment la
mise à jour des soutiens financiers des
collectivités pour assurer la couverture
des coûts de gestion des autres déchets
d'emballage la sensibilisation des
citoyens sur le geste de tri pour éviter
les risques de confusion l'implication
des collectivités dans le maillage
territorial des points de reprise et la
prise en compte des petits commerces
dans le dispositif
pour que nous puissions prendre une
décision éclairée nous devons nous y
préparer cette question doit être
débattue en concertation évidemment avec
les collectivités et avec vous c'est
pourquoi nous organiserons des
concertations techniques dès le début de
l'année 2023
l'objectif sera de poser sur la table et
conditions de la mise en place
éventuelle d'une consigne nous
discuterons également des solutions
alternatives à la consigne et c'est
ainsi en connaissance de cause que nous
pourrons prendre une décision à l'été
comme je vous l'ai démontré d'importants
moyens sont dédiés à la transition
écologique dans ce budget pour la
préservation de la biodiversité et pour
une économie circulaire performante
j'aurais besoin de tout votre soutien
pour accompagner l'ensemble de ces
politiques volontaristes et je me tiens
prête maintenant à répondre à toutes vos
questions je vous remercie
merci merci Madame et ministre pour pour
ces propos liminaires
un milliard d'arbre à planter c'est une
grande ambition
mais je vous ferai parvenir le courrier
que j'ai adressé à
au ministre de l'Agriculture il y a
quelques temps
parce que j'ai des élus dans mon
département qui ont passé des
conventions et c'est bien sur le plan de
relance pour effectivement puisque nous
on a des forêts dans le département qui
sont très très collectés pour replanter
et donc
les l'argent du plan de relancer là la
volonté des élus et là les plans sont là
et on a qu'un seul problème c'est qu'on
a personne pour les planter
et ça c'est très important parce que
effectivement l'ONF je parle pas
d'argent ONF enfin des ouvriers ONF il y
en a plus et les pépiniéristes ne
peuvent pas donc j'ai demandé à ce que
ce qui avait été accordé comme crédit
jusque fin 2023 dans le cadre du plan de
relance je sais qu'un plan de relance si
on le fait en disant on le mettra en
oeuvre dans 50 ans ça sert pas de faire
un plan de relance et puis à plein de
relance mais il faudra à mon avis le
repousser parce que et il faut surtout
qu'on puisse penser à ce problème qui
est effectivement qu'on va manquer une
main d'oeuvre pour pouvoir assumer
l'ambition qui est très loin mais qui
est important mais derrière on va avoir
ce problème voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire je veux pas prendre la parole plus
longtemps je vais donner tout de suite
la parole à Guillaume Chevrollier est-ce
que vous voulez on peut répondre déjà
peut-être à vos questions parce que vous
m'avez donc interpellé je vais finir par
le dernier sujet qui est en effet le
sujet de de du milliard d'arbre et des
plantations d'arbres vous avez raison il
y a le sujet en effet de la manœuvre
parce que ça ne se fait pas tout seul et
aussi des essences parce qu'il faut pour
ce milliardaire mais il faut bien avoir
les grains nécessaires et pouvoir les
planter donc c'est un sujet sur lequel
évidemment il y a des engagements qui
sont pris donc il y aura évidemment les
budgets nécessaires qui seront alloués
mais on viendra vers vous sur un temps
très court sur ce sujet vu que les
annonces sont récentes mais il y aura
évidemment c'est une nation une annonce
du président de la République où vous
imaginez bien que derrière on va
déployer les budgets nécessaires pour
pouvoir déployer cela vous m'avez
interrogé sur deux sujets monsieur le
Président la COP15 et évidemment donc
déjà vous précisez que moi j'y serai la
semaine prochaine à partir donc j'aurais
pas l'occasion d'être parce que vous
m'avez dit que c'était jusqu'au 14
novembre que vous aurez une délégation
sur place
27 la semaine prochaine et je serai à la
COP15 début décembre donc en effet ça ne
correspond pas aux dates que vous avez
donné j'étais resté sur la Golf 27 j'ai
une préparation à la cop27 juste avant
de venir vous rejoindre alors c'est pour
ça que ça m'a j'ai eu ce
voilà il y a eu des confusions sur le
sujet donc sur la sur la 15e cop de la
convention pour la diversité biologique
donc elle se tient en effet vous avez
raison du 7 au 19 décembre
et elle vise déjà à adopter le futur
cadre mondial pour la protection de la
biodiversité l'objectif de la France et
l'adoption d'un cadre ambitieux et
structurant qui inclut des objectifs
chiffrés avec des financements associés
et un cadre de recevabilité pour assurer
une mise en oeuvre effective la France
elle est particulièrement attachée à
l'objectif de protection de 30% des
terres et des mers
ça a été c'est porté au niveau français
mais aussi au niveau international et
c'est porté par la coalition la
coalition haute ambition pour la nature
et les peuples qui est qu'au présidé
donc par la France et le Costa Rica et
cet objectif mis en oeuvre par au niveau
national grâce à la stratégie notamment
nationale Air protégée les principaux
sujets
difficiles à négocier couvre notamment
l'inclusion d'objectifs chiffrés donc le
30 par 30 et les financements le partage
des avantages tiré de l'utilisation de
ressources génétiques et les mécanismes
de mise en oeuvre du cadre donc les
négociations s'accélèrent
comme je vous disais donc moi je serai
la semaine prochaine à la COP 27 le
président de la République s'est rendu
il y a quelques jours pour échanger avec
les partenaires mais surtout faire des
annonces importantes sur le sujet et
donc on a bon espoir d'aboutir sur le
trente par 30 on a eu des retours assez
engageant de la part du ministre chinois
qui est quand même le pays aujourd'hui
qui bloque le plus sur sur les
engagements du 30 par 30
des échanges encourageants parce que le
ministre enfin pendant longtemps la
Chine a bloqué toute négociation sur ce
sujet et là est consciente qu'il faut
envoyer un signal et donc est
probablement prête à discuter des voilà
des critères qui seront à respecter pour
ces 30% ce 30 par 30 donc j'ai bon
espoir qu'on puisse qu'on puisse aboutir
sur sur la COP15 et c'est pour ça que
j'aurai l'occasion de d'échanger avec
mon homologue chinois la semaine
prochaine à la cop27 donc c'est toujours
le vice-président le vice ministre
chinois donc ce sera l'occasion
d'aborder ce sujet sur le fond vert
donc on a parlé des 2 milliards qui ont
été annoncés pour le fond vert 150
millions d'euros minimum seront dédiés à
la biodiversité donc moi je crois sur
l'ensemble il faut évidemment
accompagner les collectivités qui
portent deux tiers des investissements
publics du pays et le fond vert va
permettre de massifier justement ces
investissements
ce qui est souhaité par le ministre
Christophe Béchu c'est un gestion souple
et proche des territoires donc on aura
des crédits qui seront délégués
directement au préfet avec des
enveloppes qui seront fongibles et le
financement ils iront vers des projets
locaux il y aura pas d'appel à projets
l'idée c'est de répondre au fil de l'eau
des demandes qui seront faites au niveau
local plusieurs sujets évidemment il y a
le sujet de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments le sujet de l'éclairage
public également le recyclage des
friches les biodéchets
et puis
sur les 150 millions minimum qui sont
dédiés à la biodiversité moi j'ai voulu
fléchir pour justement ne pas trop
avantager
un secteur plutôt qu'un autre parce que
évidemment on a un certain nombre
d'objectifs qu'on s'est fixé et qu'on
souhaiterait atteindre donc on a plutôt
fléché 65 millions d'euros pour les
espèces à protéger 20 millions d'euros
dans la lutte contre les espèces
envahissantes 20 millions d'euros pour
la dépollution de des sites et 35
millions d'euros pour la restauration de
la trame verte et bleue
il y a un autre sujet aussi c'est 100
millions d'euros qui seront dédiés à la
renaturation des villes pour une
adaptation au changement climatique
la priorité c'est de d'avoir cette mise
en place d'ici janvier 2023 avec
il y aura en tous les cas des annonces
et davantage de
d'éléments qui seront donnés notamment
sur la mise en place de de
la demande au niveau local qui sera
faite par qui sera faite au Congrès des
Maires fin novembre vous aurez plus
d'informations à ce moment-là
si vous souhaitez passer aux questions
monsieur le Président merci Madame Lamy
je vais tout de suite donner la parole à
Guillaume Chevrollier rapporteur crédit
budgétaire biodiversité paysage
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'État dans le cadre des
auditions budgétaires que j'ai conduites
sur le programme 113 plusieurs éléments
retenus mon attention je commencerai par
l'eau un sujet bien sûr que vous avez
abordé un sujet éminemment sensible avec
des territoires synthétiques qui ont
commu une forte sécheresse avec la
centaine de communes dans la capacité de
distribuer de l'eau potable à leurs
habitants et puis l'émergence des
conflits d'usage alors nous allons de
l'eau agisse au service du petit cycle
de l'eau et de la Protection des Milieux
Aquatiques avec des capacités
d'intervention dont on a pu mesurer
l'efficacité
cependant leur mission ce sont étoffés
en direction de la biodiversité et les
besoins d'investissement sur le petit
cycle de l'eau sont colossaux 4,6
milliards par an selon l'Union des
Industries entreprises de l'eau et cela
le mécanisme du plafond mordant limite
leur recette avec les traitements
au-delà de 2,2 milliards d'euros ceci
entraîne des effets pervers avec des
taxes qui sont modulées pour s'ajuster à
cet effet de seuil qu'il faut ainsi le
signal prix du coût de l'eau quel est
votre approche sur cette question pour
remédier à cette tarification de l'eau
qui n'inclut pas la réfraction
croissante de la ressource
concernant le varen agricole de l'eau et
de l'adaptation au changement climatique
comment allez-vous traduire les pistes
destinées à l'issue de cette grande
concertation notamment sur la résilience
de notre modèle agricole dans un
contexte de changement climatique
comment accompagner les agriculteurs
vers des modèles d'exploitation et
d'irrigation plus sobre
concernant les retenues colinaires qui
génèrent des contestations dans certains
territoires comment comptez-vous
accompagner les projets pour éviter ce
qui s'est produit dans les Deux-Sèvres
et quel pédagogie mettre en oeuvre dans
les cas de refus de création
enfin dernier point dans le cadre de la
Stratégie nationale biodiversité que
vous avez évoqué également j'aimerais
vous interroger sur la stratégie
nationale pour les aires protégées
l'objectif de couverture des 30% du
territoire national est déjà atteint
mais nous sommes encore loin des 10%
sous protection forte comment
comptez-vous atteindre ce seuil fixé par
la loi climat et résilience d'ici 2030
sachant qu'un rapport de l'IGF et du
CGEDD sur le financement des aires
protégés avait ressortir que la France
consacrait 600 millions d'euros
parents au financement de Césaire
protégées alors que les besoins actuels
sont estimés à plus de double donc à
hauteur de 1,2 milliards et qu'il
faudrait 1,8 soit le triple pour
parvenir
à 10% d'air sous protection forte donc
la marche est donc encore haute pour y
arriver
quels sont les stratégies que vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre pour améliorer
les financements publics comme privé en
faveur des aires protégées qui sont un
outil efficace de protection de la
biodiversité comme l'ont montré un grand
nombre d'études et il nous faut
effectivement à l'aube de la COP15 que
la France soit véritablement exemplaire
autant dans les discours que dans les
mises en œuvre effectifs sur le terrain
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre je vous propose de répondre aux
collègues
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur alors il y a eu beaucoup de
questions dans votre question donc je
vais essayer de répondre sur sur tous
les sujets
et en tout cas il y a eu plusieurs
questions sur le sujet de l'eau
j'étais ce matin même à la rencontre des
présidents des comités de bassins et on
a eu l'occasion justement d'aborder
cette question de de l'eau
évidemment les différentes solutions qui
peuvent être apportées parce qu'on va
avoir besoin évidemment de leur de
toutes leurs connaissances pour pouvoir
faire mieux et puis également le sujet
du financement
alors déjà comme je disais dans mes
propos liminaires c'est que nous on l'a
lancé ce chantier ce chantier justement
a destination de ce qui agissent au
quotidien sur la gestion de l'eau en
France pourquoi parce qu'en fait après
les Varennes de l'eau les assises on se
rend bien compte que on a un vrai une
vraie problématique depuis plusieurs
années mais particulièrement cet été ça
a été vraiment une situation hors normes
et il faut qu'on arrive à trouver des
solutions qui nous permettent de même en
situation pluviométrique
inquiétante avoir assez d'eau pour
contenter les usages les particuliers
bien évidemment les industries et aussi
le domaine agricole c'est pourquoi donc
on a lancé ce chantier on attend des
remontées déjà ils sont déjà en train de
beaucoup travailler sur le sujet et on
aura des remontées à la fin de l'année
pour pouvoir faire justement des
annonces dans le cadre de la
planification écologique de la ministre
de la première ministre pardon du coup
d'avoir des annonces extrêmement
concrètes sur le sujet on va parler de
quoi il y a le sujet évidemment de la
sobriété vous l'avez abordé il y a le
sujet aussi la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées qui on est aujourd'hui
mauvais élève en Europe et il va falloir
qu'on arrive à déployer des des projets
qui sont dans les cartons aujourd'hui et
qui attendent d'être d'être
déployé et puis aussi de revoir
probablement une partie de nos normes
qui sont assez drastiques et qui
aujourd'hui bloquent une partie des
projets qui pourraient être déployés sur
le territoire il y a des attentes fortes
nos concitoyens ils sont prêts et je
crois qu'on peut aller plus loin sur
l'arrivée vous avez parlé aussi des
retenues colinéaires
ou autrement appelé réserve de
substitution aussi et on a eu un cas
en tout cas des faits divers
particulièrement difficiles il y a
maintenant une dizaine de jours à peine
sur donc dans le dans le cadre du projet
des Deux-Sèvres bon déjà moi je tiens à
évidemment à dénoncer les violences qui
ont été qui ont été réalisés durant ces
voilà les violences contre les forces de
l'ordre aussi les menaces qui ont été
proférées envers les agriculteurs et
aussi les tous les ouvriers agricoles
présents sur site
je pense qu'on peut pas accepter cette
violence là on a sur ce cas précis en
tout cas le cas de sainte Soline mais
qui a un cas qui va à mon avis se
répéter c'est à dire qu'on a un projet
qui aujourd'hui légal où il y a eu donc
une acceptation des des du projet parce
que on a eu des analyses scientifiques
qui ont été réalisées et aussi des
contreparties importantes qui ont été
engagées par les agriculteurs notamment
la baisse de 50% des pesticides et
également une baisse drastique de la
consommation de l'eau d'eau sur ce sur
ce secteur et on se retrouve avec une
non acceptation d'une partie
militante
de de ce type de projet il est pas
question d'aller généraliser les les
réserves de substitution en France c'est
pas l'objectif jamais vous entendrez ça
de la part du ministère de la transition
écologique maintenant on doit regarder
chaque projet qui respectera des
critères extrêmement exigeants comme il
a été demandé pour s'insoline ou encore
pour le la réserve de substitution qui
est engagée à Klein dans la Vienne enfin
le projet Klein dans la Vienne voilà ce
sont des sujets qui vont évidemment être
mis sur la table ce seront des solutions
qui seront apportées probablement dans
les retours que nous aurons sur les par
les comités de bassin des comités de
bassins des présidents de comité de
bassin qui m'ont demandé d'être
davantage intégré dans le processus
d'acceptation de ce type de projet donc
moi je prends la main tendue et bien sûr
que on peut leur donner une place plus
importante dans dans ces processus et
aussi les certains élus locaux ont fait
remarquer qu'il n'avaient pas forcément
été consulté alors qu'ils allaient
accueillir à proximité ce type de de
réserve de substitution voilà donc on
est évidemment ouvert sur ce sujet je
trouve important qu'on est un moment
d'échange particulier sur les sur les
réserves de substitution compte tenues
de ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques
jours mais je veux pas laisser penser
que le temps que je passe à expliquer ce
sujet laisse penser que c'est le le la
solution la plus importante de ce qui
ressortira évidemment de de ces travaux
non pas du tout on a un travail sur la
sobriété sur la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées et bien d'autres
solutions mais aussi les réserves de
substitution sont une des solutions est
une des solutions
on a parlé également financement vous
avez abordé le sujet du plafond mordant
on m'a également
beaucoup sensibiliser sur globalement
sur le financement de l'eau et de la
biodiversité et en effet c'est un retour
que j'ai régulièrement aujourd'hui
il y a on ne bouge pas sur ce sujet du
plafond mordant mais c'est un sujet
qu'il faudra réaborder évidemment parce
que aujourd'hui on voit bien que si on
veut être beaucoup plus ambitieux sur et
apporter les moyens nécessaires aux
agences de l'eau
il faudra bien un moment donné qu'on
dégage des moyens qui permettront de
déployer un certain nombre de projets
donc la question va forcément se poser
et je trouve intéressant justement
d'avoir ces travaux qui sont organisés
parce que ça nous permettra aussi de
poser la question des financements et de
notre moment de prendre une décision
disant mais si on veut mettre en place
un certain nombre de projets il faudra
bien dégager des financements
complémentaires et donc du coup il
faudra débloquer le verrou à Bercy
voilà sur les airs protégés
oui alors sur les aires protégées alors
vous parlez de besoin de moyens moi ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que en effet
il y a un rapport qui est attendu on
aura l'occasion de travailler sur un
budget l'année prochaine pour les aires
protégées dans un premier temps on a le
budget justement dont je vous ai parlé
le budget qui concerne le fond vert et
notamment les 150 millions d'euros qui
sont dédiés donc c'est un premier volet
pour 2023 et on aura l'occasion de de
voir ce qu'il est possible de faire
justement pour les aires protégés
notamment pour les années à venir et
probablement pour même pas probablement
d'ailleurs pour le budget 2024
j'espère avoir répondu assez largement à
votre à votre question monsieur le
sénateur merci je vais donner la parole
à Fabien Genet
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'État je voudrais vous
interroger sur la politique de réduction
et de traitement des déchets vous avez
abordé déjà cette question j'aimerais
quelques précisions vous disiez que la
TGAP en particulier donne de la
visibilité alors on pourra y revenir
mais peut-être parler de visibilité à
moyen terme tout d'abord et puis ensuite
à court terme à moyen terme la
hiérarchie des modes de traitement de
déchets qui ont dû à éviter
l'élimination par stockage par
enfouissement pour cette raison la loi a
fixé un objectif très volontariste de
réduction de l'enfouissement de moitié
en 29 en 2025 par rapport à 2010 les
capacités de stockage dans notre pays
passeraient ainsi de 21 millions de
tonnes en 2015 à 13 millions de tonnes
en 2025 et 7 millions de tonnes en 2031
cette réduction des capacités de
stockage est déjà à l'œuvre on la vit
sur le terrain et mécaniquement elle
conduit à une explosion du coût du
stockage explosion du coup facturé au
collectivités et ensuite facturer aux
usagers et finalement cela correspond à
une explosion de la marge des opérateurs
privés bénéficiaires des autorisations
de stockage peut-être qu'on pourrait
déjà s'interroger sur la justesse de ce
phénomène qui conduit donc à prendre
dans la poche de l'usager pour aller
agrandir les bénéfices et les profits
des opérateurs privés qui sont encore
bénéficiaires des dernières
autorisations de stockage dans le même
temps
ce mouvement devait s'accompagner d'une
meilleure valorisation matière avec
l'extension des consignes de tri avec la
généralisation du tri à la source des
biodéchets avec la réduction des
quantités de déchets ménagers or
beaucoup de retards semblent avoir été
pris dans beaucoup de régions
où en est-on aujourd'hui et finalement
quel trajectoire de réduction de ces
déchets ménagers vous de ces déchets
ménagers constatez-vous et anticipez
vous
et à moyen terme n'y a-t-il pas un
risque que la diminution la diminution
plus rapide des capacités de stockage
qui finalement est facile à décider il
suffit de d'arrêter de donner des
autorisations de stockage que cette
diminution plus rapide que la diminution
des quantités déchets ménagers
conduisent finalement une nouvelle
explosion des coûts pour les usagers
puisqu'on aura des montagnes de déchets
et plus de capacité de stockage et donc
j'aimerais vous entendre sur cette
politique à moyen terme que vous
anticipez et puis à court terme sur
la TGAP vous nous dites elle est
nécessaire elle augmente de 2018 à 2025
ça sur le terrain et sur nos factures
d'OM on s'en rend bien compte qu'elle
augmente ça c'est indéniable
est-ce que finalement lorsqu'on se met à
la place de l'usager qui aujourd'hui
finalement voudrait peut-être trier
mieux ou se comporter mieux mais
finalement n'a pas toujours toutes les
filières de recyclage à disposition et
vous disiez vous-même dans votre exposé
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de choses à
faire à mettre en place donc s'il y a
encore des choses à faire à mettre en
place j'en déduis que tout n'existe pas
et donc l'usager n'a pas de solution
donc l'usager n'a pas de solution dans
le même temps les coûts de collecte et
de traitement explosent
conjoncturellement avec l'inflation avec
l'explosion des coûts d'énergie et en
plus vous venez rajouter cette année
2023 une TGAP qui sera supérieure à la
TGAP prévu pour 2022 et comme je n'étais
pas sûr de pouvoir vous convaincre avec
mes seuls constats de terrain je me
permettrai de vous demander si vous
partagez l'analyse de la Cour des
comptes dans son dernier rapport
qui dit dans sa conclusion le citoyen ne
peut pas être responsabilisé sur ses
déchets uniquement à travers de la
hausse des prélèvements obligatoires qui
concernent ce domaine les entreprises
les écho-organismes l'État et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
conjointement lui offrir les moyens de
modifier ses habitudes de consommation
en vue de réduire le gisement de déchets
est-ce que on voit pas là finalement la
meilleure démonstration que il serait
raisonnable au moins en 2023 au regard
de ce contexte très particulier de faire
une pause sur l'augmentation de la TGAP
pour la gelée au niveau de ce qu'elle
était en 2022 pour laisser à tous les
acteurs cette année 2023 pour mettre en
place tout ce que vous nous avez décrit
à l'instant je vous remercie merci chers
collègues j'ai donné la parole à
Frédéric marchand merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je vais
vous proposer de revenir sur le sujet
aquatique en évoquant les milieux
humides ces espaces à Fort en jeu
écologiques économiques et sociaux vous
savez la France s'est engagée à
préserver ces zones humides sur son
territoire notamment à travers la
signature en 1986 déjà de la convention
internationale de Ramsar dans mon
département le département du Nord nous
avons la chance de disposer de deux
zones humides internationales au titre
de la convention la vallée de la Scarpe
et de l'Esco ainsi que le marais aux
doomarois en lisière du Pas-de-Calais
donc avec des communes à la fois sur le
nord et sur le Pas-de-Calais alors que
le réchauffement climatique ne cesse de
s'accentuer le mois d'octobre je le
rappelle a été le plus chaud de notre
histoire que le nombre d'arrêtés
sécheresse est encore très important cet
automne notamment dans le département du
Nord ces zones recouvrent une importance
toute particulière elles doivent être
non seulement préservées mais aussi mis
en valeur la 14e Conférence des Parties
à la Convention sur les zones humides
cop14 se tient actuellement à One en
Chine et à Genève et donc c'est
l'occasion de connaître un peu vos
intentions et votre feuille de route
s'agissant du quatrième plan national
milieu humide 2022 2026 merci
merci je vais donner la parole à Bruno
rejoint
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'État je suis sénateur de
l'Allier et ce qui fait l'actualité dans
l'Allier aujourd'hui c'est la découverte
du lithium donc je vais vous parler
lithium
la présence d'une des plus fortes
réserves de lithium en Europe dans mon
département de l'Allier le projet de
lancement de la première exploitation
minière de ce matériau en France par le
groupe Imerys pourrait alimenter près de
700 000 véhicules par an dès 2028 si ce
projet
représentant près d'un milliard d'euros
d'investissement est une opportunité
évidemment pour le pays mais aussi bien
sûr une chance pour notre département
malgré tout je voudrais évoquer devant
vous quelques sujets qui sont à
travailler au sein de votre ministère
d'abord certaines populations du
département sont inquiète et souhaite
être rassuré quant à la pollution qui
pourrait être générée par cette nouvelle
ressource minière exploitée à cette si
grande échelle et donc quelle garantit
peuvent être apportées sur la sécurité
environnementale ensuite
l'exploitation effective devant débuter
en 2027 une vigilance particulière doit
à mon avis être observé quant à la
propriété de l'entreprise Imerys a-t-on
la garantie que d'ici là les années vont
passer cette société française est
détenue majoritairement par des capitaux
européens
restera dans le giron européen et ne
sera pas vendu à des acteurs chinois par
exemple
enfin
l'extraction du lithium se fera dans le
département de l'Allier mais qu'en
est-il des deux autres étapes c'est à
dire l'étape du chargement et surtout
l'étape finale du traitement de la
ressource pour conforter le dynamisme du
bassin économique de Montluçon où se
trouve cette
potentielle exploitation il est
nécessaire que l'ensemble des opérations
de valorisation soit faite localement
géographiquement localement pour éviter
des coûts de transport considérable et
en plus une pollution qui dépasserait
uniquement l'échelon de l'exploitation
donc je le dis clairement devant vous
je sais
qu'il y a des volontés autour de dire
mais bon l'exploitation à un endroit
assez bien mais la valorisation pourrait
tout à fait se faire ailleurs donc dans
mon esprit il y a une logique on ne peut
pas avoir l'exploitation d'un côté avec
inévitablement les inconvénients que ça
va générer et la valorisation ailleurs
donc je le dis clairement il me semble
important que le secteur molusionné le
bassin molusionné est particulièrement
la ville de Montluçon et bien puissent
être le lieu où seront valorisés la
ressource exploitée dans cette une
commune qui n'est pas très loin en
termes de kilomètres de cette de cette
ville voilà les trois alertes que je
voulais et mettre devant vous
aujourd'hui la première étant la
pollution environnementale
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole Daniel
oui je voulais intervenir madame la
ministre sur la question des réserves de
substitution vous y avez largement
accordé du temps donc je ne vais pas
m'étendre à nouveau sur le sujet
simplement moi je me félicite de l'état
d'esprit qui est le vôtre on vous a
écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
d'attention l'état d'esprit qui donne
dans tous les sujets que vous avez à
mettre en place concrètement sur le
terrain une large place à la pédagogie à
l'explication à l'accompagnement vous
avez dit vouloir vous appuyer sur les
collectivités les populations ma
conviction est effectivement que si il
n'y a pas d'acceptation par les
populations les collectivités au sens
large du terme quel que soit les efforts
que vous pourrez dégager on avancera pas
et que votre but est le nôtre et que
nous avantions néanmoins vous y avez
fait allusion et je voudrais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le sujet
nous allons nous trouver confrontés de
plus en plus vous l'avez dit à une
obstruction je pense violente
ultra minoritaire conduite par des
individus qui ne sont généralement pas
du tout concernés en proximité par le
projet mais dès lors que l'on décidera
de construire au-delà même d'une réserve
de se situant une route je dirais
n'importe quoi mais qui s'inscrira dans
un dans un combat et il faut absolument
que dans votre pédagogie vous prenez en
compte une réalité que on ne peut pas
d'un côté vouloir convaincre les
populations d'aller dans un sens et
d'aller vite compte tenu des urgences
climatiques et je pense que les
populations sont globalement prêtes à
jouer le jeu si d'un autre si dans le
même temps d'un autre côté une minorité
de ces populations vient casser le
travail et qui est fait sur le terrain
et désaccords qui sont trouvés en clair
il ne faut pas faire du combat pour la
biodiversité mais d'une manière générale
pour l'écologie
une multiplication sur le territoire de
chantier Notre-Dame-des-Landes qui se
termine de la même manière parce qu'à ce
moment-là il y aura un effet boomerang
des populations qui considèreront que il
n'y a pas de raison que finalement s'il
y en a qui joue pas le jeu elle le joue
et ça mettrait à mal je pense vos
efforts alors que prévoyez-vous parce
que vous ne pouvez pas au stade ou le
gouvernement j'ai écouté avec attention
les déclarations du ministre de
l'Intérieur que je partage d'ailleurs
sur les événements sainte solide et vous
ne pouvez naturellement pas je l'imagine
bien
ignorer dans l'ensemble de vos
dispositifs et de vos politiques à un
moment donné notamment ce qui vous
concerne un moment donné dans le
processus de concertation vous serez
confronté à ça et il serait il serait
intéressant pas forcément aujourd'hui
mais ultérieurement que l'on puisse
revenir ensemble sur votre approche pour
pouvoir
surpasser ces difficultés merci chers
collègues je vais donner pour conclure
cette première série de questions la
parole à Angèle Préville merci monsieur
le président madame la secrétaire
donc ma première question sera bien
évidemment sur le plastique vous nous
avez parlé d'économie circulaire alors
certes oui pour les métaux pour le verre
mais pour le plastique nous n'y sommes
pas tout à fait et vous l'avez dit seul
24% des plastiques sont recyclés et puis
nous ne heurtons à quelques
réalités j'allais dire chimiques
c'est-à-dire que tous les plastiques ne
se recyclent pas toutes les plastiques
n'ont pas des filières de recyclage en
France et
d'autre part les plastiques constituent
des polluants qui seront là dans notre
environnement pour des centaines
d'années donc voilà ce qu'il faut déjà
prendre en compte et comme vous nous
avez parlé de la transformation de la
filière textile je alors la filière
textile est principalement installée en
Asie les vêtements sont de plus en plus
jetables c'est-à-dire que je
comprends bien qu'on veuille mettre en
place des installations pour réemployer
recycler les vêtements puisque
effectivement la consommation de
vêtements à doubler en 15 ans à peine et
que cela pose effectivement un problème
son nom le problème il est effectivement
sur la masse ça c'est évident mais il
est également parce que les vêtements en
textile plastique relarguent des
microfibres en continu dans notre
environnement à la fois lorsqu'ils sont
lavés mais également lorsqu'ils sont
portés et ce sont c'est de la pollution
plastique on ne pourra jamais récupérer
donc il nous faut effectivement agir
pour essayer d'éviter au maximum et donc
je suis curieuse de connaître votre
transformation de la filière textile je
rappelle que des fibres naturelles des
fibres textiles naturelles se
décomposent dans la nature et constitue
même des nutriments dont donc aucun
impact sur l'environnement la deuxième
chose vous avez parlé de la consigne à
nouveau or vous savez bien que lorsqu'on
a
examiné la loi économie circulaire au
Sénat nous élevée contre cette cette
d'envisager cette cette éventualité de
passer à une consigne plastique je
rappelle quand même que sur nos
territoires nos syndicats qui ont été
mises en place par nos collectivités
récoltent donc les bouteilles plastiques
et cela constitue une ressource
que bien évidemment a un consommateur en
achetant une bouteille en plastique
enfin avec évidemment avec une boisson à
l'intérieur va payer l'emballage une
première fois puis va le payer une
deuxième fois si le met dans un
conteneur qui sera destiné à un
industriel
s'il le met dans le sac de tri des
collectivités ce sera une ressource pour
la collectivité s'il ne fait pas il
payera plus cher donc voilà c'est cette
problématique là qu'il nous faut
envisager on va remettre le sujet sur la
table et puis une dernière chose sur
l'eau puisque je vais je vais tout à
l'heure
je suis élu comme sénatrice à l'agence
de loi au comité de bassin de l'agence
de loi de wargaronne donc je vais y
rencontrer moi également tout à l'heure
sur les moyens et pour revenir et je
suis très très satisfaite de ce que je
vous ai entendu dire mais c'est vrai
qu'il nous faut très vite donner plus de
moyens aux agences de l'eau parce que
les sujets malheureusement sont en train
de s'accumuler alors il y a le sujet de
la sécheresse évidemment mais il y a le
sujet des micropolluants de l'eau on a
en test actuellement 500 on va en
introduire 100 de plus suite aux
directives européennes mais on sait que
il y en a il y en aurait des milliers à
rechercher et que donc au fur et à
mesure qu'on mettra des seuils et qu'on
identifiera des micro polluants à
rechercher il faudra il nous faudra
mettre en place des moyens pour réduire
cette pollution donc voilà pourquoi et
effectivement il faudrait remettre et
relever donc le plafond mordant des
agences de l'eau je vous mets
je vous propose de répondre à mes à mes
collègues avant une deuxième série de
questions
je vais essayer d'être la plus complète
possible merci monsieur le Président
alors monsieur le sénateur Genet
concernant le sujet de du poids de la
TGAP sur les finances des collectivités
territoriales qui sont gestionnaires de
déchets évidemment moi j'entends cette
difficulté j'ai beaucoup de remontées
sur sur le sujet et je suis notamment en
contact avec les associations
représentant les collectivités justement
pour travailler avec elle sur des
solutions
voilà qu'on puisse partager et qu'on
puisse justement avancer sur ce sujet
je dois vous préciser qu'il s'agit
justement du coup de stimuler la
création de ces projets en incitant tous
les acteurs du monde des déchets à
éviter la mise en décharge et
l'incinération et l'objectif est de
rendre les emplois et le recyclage plus
rentables
la trajectoire d'augmentation
progressive jusqu'en 2025 a été annoncé
dès 2018 pour donner justement de la
visibilité à tous et pour laisser le
temps au projet de se développer d'où
l'impossibilité d'arrêter le processus
et de dire on arrête alors que on
partage pas forcément je pense le
constat et je vais pouvoir vous en dire
davantage
moi je pense et je partage votre avis
sur le fait que c'est une mesure qui qui
est une mesure difficile mais elle a
porté ses fruits et elle fonctionne
ailleurs en Europe ceux qui ont
développé une trajectoire de fiscalité
déchets équivalentes ont divisé par deux
en disant les quantités de déchets
ménagers mis en décharge et en France en
2021 vous me demandiez des chiffres on a
noté une baisse de 10 à 20% des déchets
mis en décharge et de 5 à 10% des
déchets incinérés donc cette réforme de
la TGAP elle s'inscrit aussi dans un
équilibre financier sur les déchets qui
est positifs pour les collectivités il y
a en effet un surplus de recettes de
TGAP en 2020 et 2021 de plus de 80
millions d'euros par an en comparaison
avec la période précédente et plusieurs
dispositifs ont été déployés en
parallèle pour aider les collectivités
avec des montants bien supérieurs
alors tout d'abord l'état
soutien financièrement les projets de
valorisation des déchets des
collectivités à la place de la mise en
décharge et en 2021 par exemple 80
millions d'euros donc ont été affectés
directement au projet des collectivités
la baisse de TVA sur la valorisation des
déchets permet également aux
collectivités d'économiser toujours 80
millions d'euros par an et pour 2023 le
fond économie circulaire de l'ADEME à
revalorisé de 45 millions d'euros
supplémentaires et le fond vert est
ouvert au projet des collectivités sur
la collecte des biodéchets ça fait
partie donc des projets qui sont
possibles de déployer avec ce fond
j'ajoute aussi que les filières reps
sont mobilisées et pour les pour les
déchets d'emballage par exemple le
nouveau cahier des charges prévoit plus
300 millions d'euros supplémentaires en
2023 pour la prise en charge de ces
déchets et la nouvelle filière des
déchets du bâtiment permettra aussi aux
collectivités d'économiser d'ici un an
voire deux ans maximum plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros par an sur
les coûts de ces déchets
monsieur le sénateur marchand vous
m'avez
interrogé sur
les zones vous avez évoqué les zones
Ramsar et le rendez-vous phare de la
Coop qui a lieu donc du 5 au 13 novembre
2022 elle vise en effet à protéger les
milieux humides dont le rôle dans la
régulation du climat l'atténuation des
impacts des dérèglements climatiques et
le soutien à la biodiversité sont
essentiels et cette convention elle
engage les États à la conservation et à
l'utilisation durable des zones humides
et créer le zone le réseau Ramsar la 14e
Coop réaffirme notamment l'urgence de
conserver restaurer éveillé à
l'utilisation rationnelle des eaux
humides plusieurs enjeux majeurs seront
abordés déjà le sujet de la gouvernance
avec la poursuite des travaux sur le
renforcement de l'efficacité de la
convention l'amélioration de son
fonctionnement et l'articulation de ces
travaux avec les autres accords
multilatéraux sur l'environnement et
puis aussi sur le sujet bien du contenu
16 projets de résolution porteront sur
des sujets de fonds comme l'adoption du
cadre pour la préparation du nouveau
plan stratégique qui sera entériné à la
prochaine COP la France aborde la Coop
Ramsar en comptant sur un réseau riche
de citramsar couvrant plus de
3,6 millions d'hectares en métropole et
en outre-mer et demain plus encore
l'ambition de la France sur les zones
humides a été de a été renforcée par
l'adoption en mars 2022
avec le quatrième plan national en
faveur de la protection des milieux
humides
portant notamment sur la période entre
2022 et 2026 plusieurs actions renforce
l'ambition d'acquisition et de gestion
de site le fait de doubler la superficie
des milieux humides sous protection
forte en métropole d'ici 2030 de
préserver les zones par l'acquisition de
8,8 pardon 8500 hectares d'ici 2026 de
restaurer aussi 50 000 hectares de zones
humides d'ici 2026 et d'accélérer
l'extension du réseau Ramsa en France
avec la labellisation de deux sites par
an sur le territoire national la France
souhaite également engager les
collectivités les acteurs économiques
notamment en mobilisant sur les
territoires
dans une approche en fait stratégique de
leur milieu humide et aussi sur les les
secteurs les plus emblématiques au
milieu ordinaire de développer des
pratiques notamment aussi économiques et
aussi de développer des méthodes
Isabelle bas carbone qui valorise des
projets de protection et de restauration
des milieux humides
enfin l'enjeu de la protection des zones
humides et celui de la connaissance il y
a un travail de cartographie de
l'ensemble des zones humides en
françaises qui sera réalisé d'ici fin
pour qu'on ait un référentiel de au
indice 1/10
c'est une ambition une gestion
immobilisation et une connaissance c'est
l'engagement de la France pour la
protection des zones humides et sur
lequel le gouvernement travaille
quotidiennement donc c'est un sujet que
j'ai vraiment dans le SCOP et que je ne
lâche pas
vous m'avez interrogé monsieur le
sénateur rejoint sur le lithium
alors je vais essayer de vous répondre
parce que c'est un petit peu moins mon
sujet parce qu'il s'agit là pour le coup
d'un projet de transition énergétique
même si j'ignore pas que ça peut avoir
un impact sur les milieux et donc
forcément j'ai aussi un regard à porter
sur ce sujet donc je vais vous répondre
avec ce que je sais
déjà vous rappelez que la réforme du
code minier a été une avancée majeure de
la sur la loi climat et résilience elle
a permis d'avoir davantage un
renforcement de la consultation publique
déjà dans un premier temps et puis on a
une étude d'impact aussi qui est
renforcée on a une instruction des
concessions minières qui regardent aussi
la capacité des porteurs de projets et
il y a aussi des mécanismes de
protection économique des entreprises
stratégiques donc sur la la chaîne de
valeur le ministère de l'économie est
évidemment extrêmement attentif
moi je note vos alertes notamment sur
les trois aspects que vous avez évoqués
et donc on y sera vigilant et je suis
certaine qu'on reviendrait vers moi
voilà donc pour pour vous assurer qu'en
tout cas je voilà je reste cette
vigilance particulière mais en effet ça
peut avoir un impact sur sur les milieux
et donc j'y serai particulièrement
vigilante
monsieur le sénateur Guéret vous m'avez
rappelé le sujet des notamment des
réserves de substitution et vous avez
raison et je l'ai évoqué précédemment ce
seront des sujets mais d'autres aussi
qui auront nous connaîtrons probablement
des contestations beaucoup plus fortes
que nous avons connues jusque là avec
une légitimation de de d'une forme de
radicalisation
et moi ce qui me ce qui m'effraie dans
cette dans cette dans cette attitude
c'est que aujourd'hui on ne fait plus
confiance
lorsque les scientifiques se prononcent
on peut être contre un projet mais
lorsqu'il y a
des scientifiques qui se prononcent qui
donnent leur accord qui donne qui
rendent un avis et qui a un accord qui
est donné sur ce type de projet c'est
vrai qu'il est inquiétant qu'on ait
cette radicalisation qui se met en place
moi je crois beaucoup à la méthode à ce
qu'on nous avons lancé avec le ce qui a
été annoncé par le président de la
République le CNR
le CNR c'est et d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'entre vous m'ont mon
questionné sur comment ça va être
articulé sur sur le territoire et
qu'est-ce que ça va à quoi ça va servir
en plus de la planification écologique
les CNRS ils sont lancés sur cette fin
d'année moi sur un volet évidemment
biodiversité et je participe aussi à
d'autres avec d'autres ministres en
fonction évidemment de mon portefeuille
ministériel
l'idée c'est de se dire comment on va
justement faire accepter sur les
territoires ce type de projet c'est tout
à fait les questions qui vont être
posées lors de ce CNR
j'ai trois ateliers qui sont déjà
programmés et notamment comment faire
accepter les projets et quel qu'il soit
c'est à dire que là pour le coup ce sont
des projets qui sont extrêmement
contestés sur les territoires souvent
par une frange militante
souvent pas très concerné vous l'avez
dit qui ne sont pas sur les territoires
et donc on va aborder cette question et
cette question elle va être abordée
évidemment avec tous les acteurs et
aussi avec les ONG je note notamment sur
le projet de Sainte-Soline que ce projet
avait été signé avec la présence des ONG
et aujourd'hui elle se retire une partie
s'est retirée du projet de la signature
alors que enfin les étés elle le
contestait le fait qu'il y ait pas
d'avancer enfin en tout cas de baisse
significatives et de par exemple des
pesticides ou aussi la baisse de
quantité d'eau utilisée alors qu'en fait
ça pouvait pas être engagé jusque là
parce que la préfète me disait que en
fait c'était simplement il fallait
justement engager
déployer ce projet pour que ça puisse
aussi être voilà donc il fallait
attendre en tous les cas bon donc sans
parler trop de symptômes parce que je
pense que ça ça modifie le prix mais
simplement vous dire que on a bien en
tête justement l'acceptation de ce type
de projet et d'autres parce que mon avis
ça va se répéter vous avez parlé des
routes mais ça on a le projet aussi pour
les lignes LGV
et et ce type de sujets ils vont ils
vont se ils vont se multiplier donc moi
je crois beaucoup au CNR et on devra
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
pour que ces projets soient acceptés et
non plus contestés on peut pas accepter
en tous les cas ce type de mobilisation
madame la sénatrice privée vous m'avez
par vous avez évoqué deux sujets le
sujet en premier lieu de la filière
textile donc j'ai déjà donné un certain
nombre d'éléments vous avez raison moi
je crois qu'il faut
déjà mieux récupérer les textiles et
mieux les recycler mieux leur donner
aussi travailler sur la seconde vie des
textiles
et d'ailleurs on a une jeune génération
qui
est beaucoup plus adepte de la seconde
main et je trouve que c'est plutôt
encourageant d'avoir ce cette ce nouveau
type de consommation mais aussi il va
falloir responsabiliser le consommateur
et on a en parallèle engagé un travail
extrêmement sérieux parce que moi j'ai
mené justement des des concertations
pour justement la mise en place d'un
affichage environnemental
un peu sur le modèle nutriscore on est
en train de regarder justement avec les
cons enfin les associations de
consommateurs mais aussi avec les
industriels comment on peut se mettre
d'accord sur des critères qui
permettront de dire que ce produit est
plus respectueux de l'environnement que
l'autre et voilà les critères est-ce que
c'est l'empreinte carbone est-ce que
c'est le fait qu'il a été fait à l'autre
bout du monde mais le bout du monde veut
pas dire que ça a été fait dans des
mauvaises conditions et que ça utilise
une matière qui du coup pollurait notre
la nature et et notamment l'eau aussi
que que vous avez notamment évoqué donc
on est en train de regarder ça et je
pense que ce sera particulièrement
complémentaire à l'arrêt textile c'est à
dire que demain on pourra dire aux
consommateurs voilà vous achetez un
produit qui pollue et je pense que ça
c'est important parce que les les
d'ailleurs les consommateurs attendent
ce type de ce type de d'outils
vous avez parlé donc je n'oublie pas la
consigne mais vous avez parlé de l'eau
et des polluants et en effet ça fait
partie aussi du travail qui est engagé
le chantier qui a engagé le chantier
haut
on a des consommateurs qui aujourd'hui
des habitants qui doutent parfois de la
qualité de l'eau qui sort de leur
robinet et donc on doit pouvoir les
rassurer sur le sujet et on a un travail
important et moi je l'ai rappelé au
président de comité de bassin sur la
qualité des captages il faut qu'on soit
à la hauteur et aujourd'hui on est en
retard sur ce sujet donc c'est un
travail je l'ai rappelé à plusieurs
reprises au président des comités de
bassins ils l'ont bien en tête et du
coup on va travailler sur ce sujet et
donc forcément il faudra et c'est
indispensable et d'ailleurs ça faisait
partie des ateliers de ce matin des
rencontres des présidents de comités de
bassin et évidemment des directeurs des
agences de l'eau sur justement la
transition agricole
parce que c'est indispensable pour
améliorer la qualité de l'eau en France
et partout dans le monde d'ailleurs et
j'oublie pas le sujet de la consigne
bien sûr
moi j'ai vraiment évoqué un dialogue
ouvert j'ai bien d'ailleurs insister sur
le site
moi je pense que le j'ai parlé du fait
que le sujet était mûr parce que mur pas
pour la combien mais pour relancer pour
qu'il soit relancer et qu'on puisse en
débattre parce que je pense que la
situation est un petit peu différente de
je pense que d'ailleurs le dialogue a
été salvateur parce que ça a permis
d'engager le sujet même si vous avez
vous y êtes opposé et d'ailleurs je
tiens à dire que le gouvernement n'a
aucune certitude sur le sujet on
n'arrive pas avec des certitudes on est
juste face à des résultats c'est qu'on
est mauvais sur le recyclage du
plastique et donc lorsqu'on regarde nos
pays voisins on se retrouve face à des
pays voisins qui ont eux mis en place
pour certains la consigne la consigne
plastique parce que la consigne on peut
penser à la consigne verte la consigne
plastique et qui sont meilleurs que nous
dans le recyclage des plastiques donc il
faut juste qu'on se pose la question de
savoir qu'est-ce qui pourrait nous
rendre plus efficace je n'oublie pas non
plus qu'il faut qu'on arrive et ça fait
partie des objectifs qu'on sait aussi
fixés a baissé notre
notre dépendance au plastique parce
qu'en fait il ne suffit pas de dire
voilà on va continuer à produire plus de
plastique et la seule solution c'est
le recyclage donc moi je vraiment tout
est ouvert on a d'ailleurs il y a eu une
loi une proposition de loi qui a été
votée à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
réduction des plastiques j'invite le
Sénat à la reprendre et à la travailler
parce que je crois que c'est elle est
très intéressante elle était destinée
aux polystyrène et on a élargi en disant
on ne développe pas de filière de
recyclage
assez significative
dans ces cas là la matière sera
interdite à 2025 c'est ambitieux mais je
crois qu'on a pas le choix c'est à dire
qu'on doit aussi un moment donné imposé
le fait que
on si on ne peut pas recycler dans ces
cas-là c'est des matières qu'on doit
arrêter et accompagner du coup le
recyclage de ce qui est recyclable et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on réouvre le
sujet de la de la consigne qui permet de
mieux récupérer encore une fois les
plastiques pour pouvoir les diriger vers
des des filières de recyclage pour que
demain on soit pas aussi mauvais qu'on
l'est aujourd'hui mais encore une fois
tout est ouvert et moi je il y a un je
sais qu'il y a un sujet qui est très
important et vous l'avez signalé c'est
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de perte de
financement des pour les collectivités
évidemment ça fera partie je pense du
sujet presque principal des discussions
qui seront opérés avec vous mais on doit
pas nier aussi qu'aujourd'hui on a déjà
une baisse parce qu'il y a des filières
de recycle enfin de consignes sauvages
je veux dire qui sont déjà en train de
s'opérer sur certains territoires et
donc il y a certaines collectivités qui
connaissent déjà des baisses
significatives de financement donc on
peut pas l'ignorer et compte tenu des
montants vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit
madame la sénatrice des montants que
représentent aujourd'hui le prix du de
la tonne de plastique on peut pas
imaginer qu'il n'y ait pas une
augmentation de ces filières
clandestines parce que vu le prix c'est
très intéressant pour ceux qui les
mettent en place voilà donc tout est
ouvert mais je crois que c'est très
intéressant qu'on en reparle en début
d'année
merci effectivement c'est un sujet très
important parce que au-delà
effectivement des pertes de recettes que
pourrait avoir les collectivités qui en
plus sont des collectivités qui ont fait
des efforts
qui ont mis en place une politique de
tri contrairement à d'autres
collectivités qui n'ont jamais fait et
donc la problématique de ces pertes de
recettes elle sera compensée par quoi
par une hausse de la collecte et du
traitement des déchets ménagers et donc
on est dans un cercle qui peut être
vicieux parce que ce sera de dire
écoutez moi je faisais des efforts et
maintenant j'en fais moins parce que je
trie moins mais je paye plus cher
qu'avant quand je faisais les efforts
donc ça va être compliqué alors
expliquer ça c'est le premier point et
c'est pour ça que vous avez raison il
faut qu'on a vraiment qu'on en parle et
le deuxième point moi qui m'inquiète
également c'est que l'État mène des
politiques de revitalisation des centres
bourses
et derrière la machine vous rembourser
le centime d'euro ou les deux centimes
d'euros sur la consigne de votre
bouteille
l'épicier du coin je suis pas sûr qu'il
puisse s'équiper
d'une telle machine et donc ce qui fera
que l'usager fait le client se rendre à
plus facilement dans la grande
distribution qui ne pourra se rendre
dans son commerce local parce qu'il
retouchera ces deux centimes pour ces 10
bouteilles et pendant qu'il aura touché
ces deux centimes pour ses 10 bouteilles
il fera ses courses là et il fera
peut-être pas donc c'est un sujet c'est
un sujet important c'est un sujet qu'on
doit excusez-moi du mauvais termes je
dis à la poubelle comme ça mais c'est un
sujet dont on doit parler là merci la
parole est à Jean-Michel louve merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
le 15 mars dernier votre ministère a
publié donc la stratégie nationale
biodiversité 2030 d'ailleurs qui est
sous-titré premier volet précop 15 ce
document donc a été a fait l'objet de de
concertation et notamment à travers les
organismes qui ont été concernés ceci
ont été plus que réservés que ça soit le
Conseil national de protection de la
nature le Conseil national de la
transition écologique ou le Comité
National biodiversité qui chacun d'entre
eux ont un avis défavorable
néanmoins le texte a été publié la
stratégie est là le gouvernement avait
annoncé à l'époque que que il y aurait
la nécessité sans doute d'intégrer de
nouveaux le nouveau cadre mondial de la
biodiversité qui sera justement élaboré
pour la COP15 que il y aura des
révisions et des compléments et qu'il y
aura des aspects opérationnels qui
seront qui seront précisés au niveau de
la stratégie donc ma première question
c'est qu'en est-il de de cette révision
de cette stratégie nationale et puis je
voudrais sans être trop long mais
illustré par un exemple parce que vous
le savez que sous l'effet du
réchauffement des mers à l'heure
actuelle la Méditerranée orientale mais
il y a pas qu'elle notamment toutes les
eaux qui bordent les DOM-TOM et même et
même la mère de la Manche dans lequel
pour lequel je suis originaire donc sont
en train d'être envahies par ce qu'on
appelle les espèces de poissons de
Méduse et d'autres organismes marins et
dans la Méditerranée on en a
identifié plus de 900 qui ont été
observés et d'ailleurs ce qui est assez
paradoxal puisque on est maintenant dans
One océan c'est-à-dire que les mers sont
reliées les unes aux autres et que les
mécanismes
d'intrusion se font notamment par le
canal de Suez donc elle connaît cette
mer Méditerranée mais comme d'autres
mères un phénomène de tropicalisation
avec des espèces non indigènes qui sont
à la fois toxiques et venimeuses la
mesure insiste de la stratégie elle est
relativement légère si vous permettez
cette expression puisque elle s'intitule
mieux gérer les espèces exotiques
envahissantes mais elle met l'accent sur
la mise en place d'un système
d'information je sais qu'il y a eu des
opérations coup de poing qui ont été
menées notamment sur sur les espèces
invasives je sais que c'est extrêmement
difficile de savoir est-ce qu'on laisse
faire est-ce qu'on est véritablement des
stratégie de défense sachant que ça va
être difficile de lutter contre le
réchauffement des des
océans ou est-ce qu'on a les stratégies
d'adaptation donc est-ce que vous vous
avez vous préciser justement quelle est
la véritable stratégie à adopter par
rapport à ces espèces invasives
notamment mais il y a pas que
Méditerranée mais notamment Méditerranée
si demande de parole
Louis Jean Nicolay après Renault Dantec
Hervé gilet Jean-Claude Anglard n'a déjà
fait et Evelyne Perrot oui merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
d'abord demain je crois que vous allez
en Indre-et-Loire sur le site de Calcia
moi je suis dans la Sarthe si vous
traversez le ruisseau vous serez dans la
Sarthe mais si vous traitée vous
resterez en Indre-et-Loire mais je pense
que vous resterez vous resterez en être
loin en tout cas vous verrez c'était une
commune extrêmement sympathique juste
deux mots d'abord un premier mot pour
soutenir en gel Préville sur le problème
des vraiment et le président Longeot sur
le problème de la collecte des ordures
ménagères et les syndicats d'ordures
ménagères publiques parce que ça va être
d'abord aujourd'hui l'essentiel des
syndicats sont financés par la taxe
d'ordures ménagères ils ont essayé
beaucoup la redevance et devenait très
compliqué et donc c'est le foncier bâti
qui sert de financement et que si et ça
sera extrêmement compliqué d'expliquer
la la citadine si en même temps des
consignes à côté pour ceux qui auront
bénéficiant du syndicat dans les maisons
enfin c'est un vrai chantier sur lequel
il faut faire attention deux points
permettaient sur la chasse puisque vous
êtes en respectant responsabilité sur la
chasse je comprends parfaitement les
volontés du gouvernement sur la question
de sécurité haute mais je crois que la
chasse elle est pas la même dans le nord
de la France en Bretagne dans le sud
dans l'Ouest et cetera et que par
conséquent le rôle des fédérations est
extrêmement important pour
l'organisation sur les territoires il y
a des territoires on a entendu que
peut-être le dimanche il faudrait ne
plus chasser mais ça ça concerne c'est
vrai tout autour la région parisienne où
les gens des grandes villes vont se
promener aux alentours et dans des
milieux rurales c'est le contraire
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont le dimanche pour
chasser simplement parce qu'il travaille
quelquefois du lundi au samedi notamment
les artisans et les commerçants donc je
crois que sur le problème de la chasse
il faut quand même faire attention et
laisser vraiment aux fédérations
départementales peut-être régionale s'il
le faut le soin de de vous aider à
organiser ces territoires le deuxième
point je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
la continuité écologique sur les cours
d'eau
continuité écologique c'est pas dans les
cours d'eau et notamment la
problématique des barrages bon les
barrages ont longtemps pendant longtemps
on a on a dit que c'est barrages
empêchaient la cause écologique les
poissons etc certains barrages ont des
centaines et des centaines d'années je
ne peux pas sûr que c'est éviter
empêcher la continuité écologique et ça
joue un rôle extrêmement important pour
notamment l'irrigation pour les
maraîchers pour les agriculteurs plutôt
que d'aller pomper dans le cylomania
comme beaucoup le fait à partir de la
sécheresse de 76 on a connu en 76 une
grande sécheresse qui a permis de faire
des puits de 560 à 180 mètres il faut
peut-être lui retenir l'eau et en
profiter avec ses barrages sur les
communes sans parler la petite
hydroélectricité sur lequel on s'est
défendu on s'est battu à une heure et
demie du matin dans des plaies à
certains pour essayer de faire passer
des amendements là maintenant je vous
remercie je crois je suis désolé mais je
suis obligé de partir pour prendre un
train et je m'a pas votre réponse mais
je suis sûr qu'elle sera très
intéressante
merci la parole est en haut dans un
texte merci monsieur le Président je
remercie d'avoir notre collègue Louis
oui Jean-Nicolas il parce que pour enfin
clairement je crois que ça avait jamais
été vraiment dit de dire que derrière
les hydroélectricité la croyance dans le
fait d'avoir des réserves d'eau
supplémentaires régler l'électricité à
peut avoir dans cette affaire
la pie-grièche à poitrine rose a disparu
de France l'année dernière vous parliez
de cette extinction silencieuse c'est un
oiseau Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle la
confirmé dans son dernier rapport qui a
totalement disparu de de France
aujourd'hui ça pose effectivement la
question de notre gestion des espèces
menacées
lors de la loi sur la biodiversité dans
le rapporteur et notre collègue Jérôme
Bignon c'était maintenant il y a 7 huit
ans avec Ségolène Royal communiste nous
avions rendu obligatoire dans la loi et
d'ailleurs le ministère ne met toujours
en gras sur son site les programmes
nationaux d'action pour les espèces
menacées de la liste rouge U7 donc pour
toute espèce menacée l'état normalement
produit un PNA donc ma question sur les
PNA qui est un peu une question triple
c'est d'abord est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
cette huit ans après on a eu un peu de
temps quand même toutes les espèces
menacées de la liste rouge sont
effectivement couvertes par un programme
national d'action ça c'est la première
question
ensuite on en est du financement de ces
programmes nationaux d'action là par
exemple pour prendre un exemple le gecko
vert de la Réunion qui est absolument
le programme d'action a été validé je
crois l'année dernière pour à peu près 3
millions d'euros ça donne une idée mais
est-ce qu'on a les moyens financiers de
couvrir tous les tous les programmes
nationaux d'action c'est la deuxième
question et la troisième je reviens sur
ma pigrièche parce qu'on n'est pas
totalement responsable de la disparition
de l'Afrique Grièges à poitrine rose pas
les autres pigriches je vous rassure il
y a encore des petits grillages en
France c'est c'est quand même très lié
aussi à la migration de l'espèce et
assez difficulté sur d'autres sur
d'autres pays je vois qu'il y a des
connaisseurs dans la salle ce qui veut
dire que dans nos programmes nationaux
d'action on doit avoir un volet
obligatoire de coopération
internationale sinon ça ne marche pas
c'est beaucoup d'espèces qui sont
migratrices si on se contente
d'agir chez nous elle disparaîtront
quand même donc dans ces PNA qu'elle est
aujourd'hui la stratégie surtout avant
la coop à Montréal de de coopération
donc voilà un bloc de question sur les
PNA et je réagis à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure
sur un autre le point où vous avez parlé
à peu près 200 millions d'euros pour la
forêt je crois que c'est le chiffre que
vous avez donné
je rejoins l'inquiétude du président
Longeot sur le fait de savoir si on a
vraiment les moyens humains de replanter
aux échelles annoncées moi ma question
puisque vous avez parlé derrière je l'ai
bien noté de la finance carbone comme on
a deux programmes de compensation qui
vont rapporter quand même pas mal
d'argent
ressent et 120 millions d'euros par an
qui sont liés à Saint-Avold et accordé
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous allez
mettre un tuyau direct du financement de
la compensation des deux centrales à
charbon qu'on a ouvert en urgence pour
financer la forêt en priorité ce qui
poserait un certain nombre de questions
sur la compensation et de la finance
carbone d'équivalence quand même entre
l'État ennemises et les tonnes captées
je vais donner la parole à Jean-Claude
Anglard
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
voulais saluer madame la ministre votre
volontarisme
ma question porte comme Roland Dantec
sur par la disparition mais la
diminution du nombre d'agriculteurs et
je peux parler des agriculteurs éleveurs
les agriculteurs éleveurs dont le nombre
diminue de façon drastique et dans les
troupeaux vaches ou 20 disparaissent et
ma question porte pas sur les
agriculteurs mais sur les prédateurs
puisque vous avez dit que c'était votre
compétence ils ont j'aimerais vous
entendre sur le sujet du loup
le sujet du vautour et le sujet du
râteau pied les trois prédateurs je vous
parle pas du rat de Paris le surmulot là
il nous a mis écolo
du Rat des champs du vautour et du
Louvre j'aimerais vous entendre dessus
sur le sujet puisque je pense que c'est
une histoire de méthode par rapport à la
gestion de ses prédateurs j'aimerais
vous entendre là-dessus merci
merci je vais donner la parole à Nadège
avait et puis pour conclure à Evelyne
perron merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre excusez-moi non j'ai
fait l'erreur j'ai oublié il était avant
non j'ai oublié Hervé gilet oui oui je
donne la parole Hervé gilet désolé pour
ma collègue
c'était tu étais avant
pas de soucis merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre tout
d'abord vous avez fait une communication
concernant les CRPE renforcés par le
fond vert on ne peut que saluer bien sûr
cette orientation je voudrais simplement
souligner que à l'heure actuelle des
CRPE et pas que les certe d'ailleurs
d'une manière plus générale un certain
nombre de politiques contractuelles ne
sont pas conditionnés et il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui d'objectifs qui sont
assignés dans le cadre d'un certain
nombre de politiques publiques qui sont
mis en place et de fait comme il n'y a
pas d'objectif particulier
c'est un peu délicat donc par exemple
prenons les CRPE même si c'est peut-être
pas votre compétence directe mais je
pense que vous avez quand même
visiblement une application quand même
sur le sujet continue du document que
j'ai sous les yeux
en tout état de cause la notion
d'objectif et de conditionnement est une
notion intéressante dans la mise en
place des politiques publiques et il
serait intéressant d'avoir votre avis
sur ce sujet sur la restauration des
continuités écologiques Louis-Jean est
parti mais pour moi j'ai un avis inverse
il s'avère que la décision qui a été
prise dans ce cas de figure la meilleure
difficulté les agences de l'eau et par
ailleurs même au sein de notre
commission on a vu que cette décision
qui a été prise dans le cadre de la loi
climat était loin d'être facilitante
pour le coup elle n'était pas
judicieusement
ajustée pourrait-on dire il y avait une
position d'équilibre qui avait été
trouvée au sein de la commission et qui
a été d'ailleurs acceptée et qui est
tout à fait qui était tout à fait
judicieux pour trouver un bon équilibre
entre la restauration des continuités et
éventuellement le cas échéance au
couvert d'une étude approfondie le
maintien
d'une
le maintien d'une limite ou d'un barrage
à partir du moment où trouver des
solutions effectivement alternatives je
voudrais vous alerter également sur le
fait qu'aujourd'hui on ne parle plus de
loi sur l'eau mais qu'il y a des
nécessités d'avoir des évolutions
profondes en la matière et notamment en
termes de gouvernance je voudrais mettre
en perspective le Livre bleu que
l'Agence Nationale des études bassin a
présenté très récemment nous aurons
l'occasion d'ailleurs de les auditionner
au sein même de notre commission mais on
voit bien qu'il faut renforcer les
gouvernances territoriales et dans ce
cas de figure les établissements publics
territoriaux de bassin sont quand même
une structure vraiment intéressante il
faudrait les conforter j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur ce sujet là et notamment
ce qu'on appelle le réseau en tant que
tel avec les épages pour être plus dans
une politique de gouvernance
territoriale affirmé et de solidarité
affirmée entre l'amant et Laval et puis
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a des
difficultés particulière vis-à-vis du
réchauffement climatique par rapport aux
étiages sévères que nous avons pu subir
je prends un exemple je suis l'ancien
président du smeac syndicat mix d'études
d'aménagement de la Garonne le soutien
des tirages duraient jusqu'à mi-octobre
aujourd'hui compte tenu des contraintes
on est obligé de soutenir encore la
Garonne après le 31 octobre toutes les
conventions étaient avec EDF et les
barrages hydroélectriques jusqu'au 31
donc on est en grande difficulté et les
services de l'État sont en grande
difficulté de renégociation des lâcher
d'eau puisque quelque part on est hors
convention donc on a un système qui est
à bout de souffle aussi dans ce cas de
figure et vous savez que dans le cas de
la renégociation au niveau des
conventions hydroélectriques ce sujet a
eu un important toute particulière donc
il faudra bien évidemment préserver la
capacité à turbiner pour produire de
l'électricité mais la capacité au niveau
des grands réservoirs de soutenir aussi
les étiages avec des polydes de
politiques de solidarité inter-bassin et
j'aimerais également avoir votre avis
sur le sujet je vous remercie
merci la parole est un Nadège merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
fin avril 2022 le gouvernement a publié
une liste de 126 communes qui seront les
plus menacées par l'érosion côtière et
qui devront s'y adapter en Bretagne il y
a 41 villes qui sont concernées dont
plus de la moitié dans le département du
Finistère c'est normal avec 1200 km de
côte celui-ci est particulièrement
exposé les élus vont devoir donc
réaliser des cartes du risque de recul
du littoral à horizon 30 ans et 100 ans
sur cette base seront établis des
nouvelles règles d'aménagement du
territoire en manière d'urbanisme se
pose nécessairement la question d'un
accompagnement pérenne financier et en
matière d’ingénierie puisque des
municipalités pour relever ces défis
colossaux auront quelques difficultés
madame la ministre quels sont les
crédits portés pour l'année 2023 afin de
soutenir les élus dans ce travail et à
quelle fin le fond vert sera-t-il un
levier activé pour ce faire et quel
budget pérenne pour faire face à ce
phénomène massif puisque plus Google
alors que près de 900 communes sont
particulièrement vulnérables aux
submersions marines et que 1,5 millions
d'habitants vivent dans les zones
inondées littorales il est absolument
nécessaire de donner une visibilité au
territoire les plus en danger je vous
remercie
merci la parole de Evelyne Perrault
merci président madame la ministre vous
avez parlé de zones et j'habite en
Champagne humide donc la Champagne
humide c'est avant tout des forêts et
des prairies en 85
étant donné que l'élevage disparaissait
les prairies ont été retournés drainés
et
pour être en blavé
emblée enfin en
betterave et aujourd'hui avec le
réchauffement climatique les les
terres sont fissurées mais vous pouvez
avoir des des lézards qui font 10 à 20
cm de large et ces prairies se
trouvaient autour des des villages donc
ce qui servait voyez-vous pendant quand
la prairie était gorgée d'eau ça servait
de
d'élastique à la limite entre les les
constructions les terres les prairies et
les constructions ce qui permettait
d'avoir une certaine oui je me répète
élasticité de des terres et aujourd'hui
avec la sécheresse et bien c'est c'est
fissures qu'on remarque dans les champs
elle se prolonge jusque dans les maisons
et il n'y a absolument plus cet
élasticité qui était qui était tout à
fait normal avec avec
la prairie donc je j'ai fait faire dans
mon village une une cartographie
des zones humide je pense que ces
cartographies pour les terres où il y
avait énormément d'élevage et comme
l'élevage disparaît devrait devenir
obligatoire parce que vraiment ça sert
et ça permettrait d'éviter des
constructions à des endroits qui sont
qui deviennent impossible par la suite
voilà merci
merci madame la ministre je vous propose
de répondre à mes collègues merci
merci monsieur le Président je vais être
essayer d'être la plus complète possible
alors monsieur le sénateur Houlgate
sur le sujet de la stratégie nationale
biodiversité on a eu un premier volet en
mars dernier dont les avis étaient
achetés mitigés pourquoi parce qu'en
fait il manquait des indicateurs
également des objectifs chiffrés et
aussi les moyens c'est à dire les
financements qui permettaient
d'atteindre justement ces objectifs donc
on a repris moi avec ma nomination donc
reprise travail
on va justement utiliser le fond vert
avec ses financements qui sont justement
importants qui sont dégagés et qui sont
fléchés vers la stratégie nationale
biodiversité on a aussi une progression
du programme central qui va nous
permettre aussi d'avoir des moyens
j'ai remis au travail les membres les
nouveaux membres parce qu'il y a des
anciens mais il y a aussi des nouveaux
du Comité National biodiversité donc ça
c'était fin octobre qui se sont réunis
et donc du coup on va
aboutir et là pour le coup ce sera
courant 2023 et ce sera d'ailleurs
plutôt mars 2023
c'est en tous les cas le l'échéance qui
a été donné et donc
voilà le travail est engagé sur ce sujet
vous m'avez également parlé des espèces
exotiques envahissantes
moi je partage votre inquiétude sur le
sur le sujet parce que on a ce risque
sur nos territoires et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs évoqué autant dans l'Hexagone
que en outre-mer et l'Union européenne a
mis en place une réglementation qui est
contraignante en 2014 qui est basée sur
une liste d'espèces soumises à de
nombreuses interdictions l'importation
libération dans l'environnement et aussi
la commercialisation et à ce jour on a
88 espèces exotiques envahissantes qui
sont réglementées en métropole
le précédent gouvernement a lancé début
2022 un plan d'action qui vise à
renforcer les aspects de surveillance et
de contrôle
il y a aussi l'état qui finance des
opérations de gestion dites opération
coup de poing ce dispositif qui
s'inscrit dans la stratégie nationale
biodiversité
2022-2030 qui sera reconduit jusqu'en
2026 il sera financé par le fond vert
aussi à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
et cela permettra de financer 250
opérations par an partout sur le
territoire et cela dès 2023 la mesure
financera des opérations locales
impliquant des acteurs divers et
concernant les végétaux il peut s'agir
de fauchage d'arrachage d'implantations
d'espèces locales concurrentes et
concernant les animaux il s'agit de tir
ou de piégeage
il y a une forte proportion de ces
opérations
qui concerne le territoire ultramarin
environ un tiers voilà ce que je peux
vous dire
sur le sujet pour répondre rapidement au
sénateur de Nicolas qui nous a quitté et
notamment sur le sujet de la chasse et
l'inquiétude de cette demi-journée
s'enchasse moi j'ai simplement évoqué
que aucune piste n'était écartée dans le
rapport de qualité encore une fois qui a
été réalisé par les sénateurs
ce sujet n'a pas été tranché mais n'a
pas été mis de côté non plus c'est à
dire que je pense qu'il faut avoir une
des discussions sur les territoires
en effet on ne regarde pas la chasse
dans le Nord comme la chasse dans le sud
on ne regarde pas les chasses sur des
forêts périurbaines comme sur des forêts
en ruralité donc voilà moi il y a une
ouverture sur ce sujet le sujet est sur
la table parce que c'est une des
solutions qui permettrait de coexister
c'est à dire de d'avoir un certain
partage de l'espace et surtout du temps
voilà donc en tout cas c'est mais moi ce
que je répète souvent sur ce sujet c'est
que
imaginez que c'est la seule solution et
la solution miracle pour favoriser la
sécurité à la chasse c'est faux
et donc ça fait partie
de plusieurs
propositions possibles mais encore une
fois rien n'est statué et j'ai des
discussions très nourries avec la
Fédération nationale de la chasse et
notamment son président wishman avec
aussi et je rencontrerai d'ici quelques
jours les ONG représentatives également
aussi les élus locaux qui se sont
manifestées et que bien sûr je vais
rencontrer voilà l'idée c'est d'ouvrir
évidemment les discussions sur ce sujet
pour aboutir avant avant Noël
monsieur le sénateur dans tech
vous avez
abordé les espèces menacées et leurs
habitats notamment parmi d'autres aussi
d'autres sujets en fait en complément
des règles de protection justement il
nous faut des plans de pour restaurer
les espèces menacées et leur habitat et
c'est justement le rôle des plans
nationaux d'action et et je peux vous
assurer qu'on les poursuit et on va
évidemment travailler sur ces sujets
l'idée c'est d'imaginer les financiers
évidemment en partie avec le fond vert
qui est dégagé pour 2023 le fond vert il
a pour objectif d'être enfin on a
l'objectif avec le ministre qui sauvechu
de pérenniser
c'est pas juste 2 milliards d'euros pour
2023 l'idée c'est qu'on est justement un
financement qui soit
pérennisé et c'est justement l'idée de
cette planification écologique c'est
comment on met les moyens pour justement
atteindre les objectifs qu'on se fixe
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur le sujet
des oiseaux qui est un sujet évidemment
important
il y a là pour le coup c'est un travail
davantage à l'international qu'il faut
mener et ça fait partie des discussions
notamment sur les sujets biodiversité
qu'on doit
engager dans le cadre de la COP 27 la
COP15 et donc ça fait partie évidemment
des sujets
j'avais également noté le mot pollution
mais je sais plus quel sujet
le lien entre la compensation carbone
Cordemais Saint-Avold et la restauration
des forêts françaises
voilà je voulais vous répondre sur le
sujet alors
qui est pas forcément favorable on n'a
pas tendance à faire ce genre de choses
maintenant
qu'il faille qu'on baisse
les subventions à tout ce qui est lié
aux énergies fossiles
à très court terme ça c'est une
certitude c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
qu'on fasse attention à fait à
l'équilibre que nous avons et qui est
budgétaire c'est-à-dire qu'on doit
davantage inciter à avoir des pratiques
vertueuses plutôt que de continuer à
utiliser
tout ce qui est polluant et par exemple
c'est souvent pris en exemple c'est pour
ça que je le cite lorsqu'on accompagne
les Français notamment sur les 30
centimes de remise à la pompe il est
certain que ça va pas dans le sens de la
transition écologique parce que on a
donc c'est une mesure d'urgence il faut
qu'on accompagne les Français et donc on
y agit sur le sur le court terme parce
qu'il y a une nécessité mais maintenant
il est évident que ça peut avoir une
incidence sur notamment la transition
écologique énergétique qu'on est en
train de mener sur le fait d'avoir aussi
des investissements de nos industriels
notamment français et automobile sur
justement le parc automobile pour aller
vers des vers des solutions plus propres
et donc tout ça il faut que qu'on soit
vigilant est-ce que pérennise pas ce
type de subvention et que à terme on est
déséquilibre beaucoup moins important et
qu'on soit justement à financer Dav de
voilà de pratiques vertueuse c'est bien
l'objectif
monsieur le sénateur anglais
alors déjà vous m'avez interrogé sur les
agriculteurs
en effet il y a une
baisse du nombre de d'agriculteurs
notamment
surtout c'est surtout les éleveurs qui
sont concernés
on a eu une année particulièrement
difficile avec une sécheresse importante
qui a découragé un certain nombre
d'éleveurs pourquoi parce que on a une
baisse la production de fourrage compte
tenu de la sécheresse extrêmement forte
qu'il y a eu et donc il y a eu des choix
parfois extrêmement difficiles d'arrêter
en fait
l'élevage est plutôt d'amener
les bêtes à l'abattoir
notamment celle qui était enfin qui qui
produisait du lait notamment aussi les
vaches laitières parce que justement il
y avait plus de quoi les nourrir donc
c'est un sujet que que j'ignore pas un
sujet qui me préoccupe parce que
évidemment on a le souhait le
gouvernement porte en tout cas ce
souhait d'avoir une agriculture forte et
qu'on puisse être autonome en France en
tout cas à son maximum et donc ça ça ne
va pas dans ce sens compte tenu qu'on a
des pertes d'exploitation donc ça j'y
suis évidemment extrêmement sensible et
on y travaille avec avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture pour justement accompagner
nos éleveurs
vous m'avez interrogé sur les prédateurs
alors particulièrement sur le loup je
vous dis tout de suite je n'aurais pas
de réponse à vous donner là sur les
rates je ne suis pas assez calée sur le
sujet j'ai eu pourquoi parce que non pas
que ça m'intéresse pas mais disons que
j'ai eu beaucoup à travailler depuis
quelques semaines particulièrement ces
derniers jours sur le loup et sur l'ours
qui sont évidemment des les grands
prédateurs qui aujourd'hui sont les plus
évoqués dans les territoires et je sais
particulièrement dans cette dans cette
assemblée que que c'est particulièrement
préoccupant et je suis extrêmement
sollicitée sur le sujet donc sur le loup
on a une population du loup qui a
dépassé en 2019 le seuil de viabilité
démographique de 500 individus qui
avaient été fixés
l'effectif est à peu près estimé à 920
loups à l'hiver 2021 2022 et du coup il
évolue très vite depuis 4 ans la
population du Pinat donc a quasiment
doublé et l'expansion géographique se
poursuit très régulièrement avec un
nombre de zones de présence de loups qui
croit fortement on a un plan national
d'action loue et activités d'élevage
2018-2023 qui est piloté par le préfet
de la région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes il
repose sur le financement des mesures de
protection l'indemnisation des dommages
également le suivi de la population
lupine et les interventions des tirs
létaux et la recherche scientifique
alors on constate une stabilisation des
dégâts depuis trois ans
environ 12000 individus et l'an dernier
pour la première fois le nombre
d'attaques a également diminué d'environ
3%. donc l'État a mis en place un cadre
pour le financement des mesures de
protection qui s'est développé on compte
plus de 20% de contrats de protection
signé par les éleveurs depuis le début
du plan en 2018
on a donc un préfet coordinateur loup
qui se dédie entièrement sur le dossier
Lou et
il faudra on a un plan d'action qui doit
être revu en 2023 donc pour
un temps de 2024 2029 donc un plan 2024
2029 où là il va falloir redéfinir ce
plan donc il y a une discussion
extrêmement
importante donc avec avec le qui est
observé avec avec les acteurs mais aussi
avec évidemment le ministre de
l'Agriculture sur ce sujet
il faut voir comment on peut
continuer à cohabiter avec avec les
grands prédateurs le cas interrogé sur
l'ours mais c'est un sujet qui est très
très important aussi surtout dans les
territoires du Sud-Ouest
il va falloir qu'on arrive enfin si
c'est deux sujets différents et en tout
cas sur le loup
il faut qu'on voit comment on arrive à
cohabiter
mais je sais que c'est un sujet
extrêmement extrêmement prégnant sur sur
certains territoires surtout sur les
territoires où le loup vient d'arriver
c'est à dire que on se rend compte que
les territoires ou le loup est arrivé
depuis quelques années
les les éleveurs ont se sont organisés
et se sont protégés
et là on a des territoires qui sont
nouvellement touchés par l'arrivée du
loup ils sont parfois différents qui ont
pas le même type d'élevage aussi bien
sûr ils sont pas en montagne qui sont
dans d'autres et voilà et bien sûr je
l'ignore pas mais en tout cas on a il y
a pas le même niveau de protection qui
est mis en place et donc du coup ça a
des conséquences notamment sur les
troupeaux en effet
bonne nouvelle
monsieur le sénateur gilet alors
je suis assez surprise vous m'interrogez
sur le CRPE vous dites voir mon nom
alors je veux pas contredire vous avez
un document à la pluie
oui
oui sur la contractualisation en effet
c'est vrai
c'est un sujet qu'il faudra qu'on
réaborde en effet mais interrogé aussi
sur les lots et notamment sur le poids
des comités de bassin et je l'ai dit en
propos liminaire et je l'ai rappelé
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
évidemment il y a le conseil
d'administration qui qui rend des avis
sur le sujet notamment j'ai dit sur les
sur le projet par exemple de réserves de
substitution ils demandent à être
davantage
engager dans le processus moi je
leur propose aussi de s'auto saisir
ils sont totalement libres de s'auto
saisir sur un sujet qui concerne leur
territoire donc là dessus évidemment en
tout cas moi tout ce qui pourra
permettre de redonner du poids aux
instances locales sans évidemment créer
de lourdeur parce que le but c'est
évidemment qu'on arrive à déployer un
certain nombre de projets et que ce soit
pas trop compliqué ce que j'ai pu noter
lorsque j'ai fait un déplacement avec la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
ruralité dans la Drôme on était début
août dans des moments extrêmement
compliqués avec des niveaux c'est simple
il y avait pu il y avait plus d'eau dans
les cours d'eau
on a fait un moment une table ronde avec
avec beaucoup d'acteurs tous les acteurs
qui sont justement en lien avec la
gestion de l'eau du département et ce
qu'ils étaient assez ils étaient assez
unanimes autour de la table pour dire
qu'en fait il y avait tellement
d'acteurs que parfois il ne savaient
plus non plus qui devait prendre les
décisions
qui était voilà qui était la le l'acteur
qui devait
décider prendre la décision définitive
et donc je crois qu'il faut aussi sans
remettre en cause nullement le fait que
ce soit une politique décentralisée
enfin je veux dire je crois que c'est
assez la politique la plus ancienne
enfin la plus celle qui est la plus tôt
décentralisée l'une des plus tôt des
centralisée et qui fonctionne c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas une remise en cause
du tout c'est pas pour une reprise par
l'État l'État doit accompagner les
collectivités accompagner les comités de
bassin pour avoir une gestion de l'eau
plus plus
viable parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il y a des il y a des limites
mais je crois qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
aussi évoquer le sujet de la gouvernance
au-delà des sujets du sujet des des
retours d'expérience et des projets qui
peuvent être déployés sur les
territoires je crois que le sujet
gouvernance doit être être évoqué pour
encore une fois simplifier sur les
territoires et non pas que l'État
reprenne la main
madame la sénatrice avait qui est partie
je comprends parce que du coup on passe
un moment mais je crois que c'est
important aussi que que je vous donne
des réponses les plus complètes
possibles
sur le sujet pour être assez rapide et
synthétique sur le sujet du trait de
côte
aujourd'hui il y a des financements qui
sont engagés pour l'ingénierie à hauteur
de 20 millions d'euros d'ailleurs c'est
un budget qui sera de 20 millions
d'euros pour 2023
on a un engagement justement sur
l'ingénierie et sur les cartographies
pour accompagner justement les
territoires et voir comment justement
les territoires vont évoluer qui
puissent se préparer
moi j'ai déjà annoncé et ça c'était lors
des lors du congrès de la neige
qu'on allait engager justement des
discussions
déconcertation pour avoir un financement
beaucoup plus enfin sur la continuité
c'est à dire que ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on arrive à un modèle de
financement qui permette d'équilibrer on
peut pas tout faire peser sur les
collectivités territoriales et en même
temps on peut pas tout faire peser sur
l'état donc c'est comment on arrive à se
mettre d'accord les élus me disaient
mais on vous a fait un certain nombre de
propositions vous avez plus qu'à les
reprendre oui mais sauf que lorsque je
regarde le nombre de propositions j'en
ai une petite dizaine sur les modes de
financement et qu'en fait on ne s'est
pas mis d'accord
donc en fait moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'on reprenne justement la discussion
et c'est pour ça qu'il va y avoir une
concertation que j'engageais en tout
début d'année et qui sera effectivement
et l'idée c'est d'aboutir probablement
là pour le coup si on arrive au bout
d'un an ce sera sur le PLF 2025 mais ça
permettra d'avoir à peu près 30 ans moi
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on engage à
peu près 30 ans de visibilité sur les
financements pour nous amener à 2050 et
puis je laisserai les gouvernements
suivants engagés l'avenir après 2050
mais je pense que déjà si on arrive à
avoir une trentaine d'années de
visibilité sur ce sujet je pense que ça
rassurera évidemment et surtout les
communes du littoral
voici et sinon sur madame la sénatrice
Perrault sur les zones humides moi j'ai
commencé déjà y répondre un certain
nombre de sur un certain nombre de
sujets sur le sujet des zones humides
comme je dis c'est que il faut qu'on
arrive à les préserver
c'est évidemment soit extrêmement
précieuses sur notre territoire et elles
ont souvent été sujets
à un désintérêt et donc une mise de côté
et une destruction de ces zones humides
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
d'appeler à ce qu'elle à ce qu'elle
revienne je crois qu'on a aussi une un
devoir d'exigence et on doit être
d'ailleurs on le demande d'ailleurs
souvent et ça nous est reproché par les
pays du Sud avec qui au niveau
international on demande de préserver
leur zone humide ils lui disent mais
vous qu'est-ce que vous avez fait et
comment vous les restaurer donc je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit voilà responsable
et qu'on réengage en tous les cas la
protection des zones humides et qu'on
les restaure pour une partie d'entre
elles qui ont disparu
je l'ai indiqué notamment on est on n'a
pas mis de côté le fait d'avoir un parc
zonumide en France en 11e parc aux eaux
humides donc voilà je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est envisageable il y
a certains sites qui sont
aujourd'hui qui qui pourrait être
sélectionné maintenant il faut avouer
qu'il y a des contraintes importantes et
que c'est pas toujours bien accueilli
par les élus locaux parce que justement
il y a des contraintes et donc du coup
ça mettra un certain nombre d'années je
pense à aboutir mais en tout cas le
sujet est toujours évidemment sur la
table et je et je n'ai pas abandonné le
11e parc zonymie en France
moi j'habite le Parc Naturel Régional de
la Forêt d'Orient donc il y a quand même
5000 hectares de bandeaux tout à fait
bien merci mes mes chers collègues merci
merci madame la ministre pour pour cet
échange
que je peux qualifier et change riche et
positif de nombreux de nombreux sujets
on fait l'objet d'un certain nombre de
questions importants sujet
relativement simple pour certains à
traiter d'autres un peu plus complexes
et compliquées et qui mérite et vous
l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises et je
m'en réjouis d'un dialogue élargi je
pense à la chasse je pense effectivement
à la problématique de la consigne à la
coexistence entre
entre les prédateurs l'élevage c'est
vrai que vous l'avez dit je dis pas que
ça va beaucoup mieux dans les dans les
secteurs où mais il y a une certaine
habitude mais moi dans mon département
le ministre de l'Agriculture est
d'ailleurs venu parce qu'il y a eu 29
attaques de génisses et c'est vrai que
la réaction et il faut qu'on évite ça
par le dialogue par la discussion par
essayer de trouver des solutions parce
que la solution miracle celle de dire on
tire bah oui très bien pourquoi pas mais
je suis pas sûr que ou alors on ne fait
rien et je suis pas sûr que ce soit
aussi la solution donc je pense que tout
ça ça passe par une véritable
concertation et par par vraiment une
discussion
c'était tout ça mérite un vrai dialogue
et une vraie réflexion
sur la dernière réponse que vous avez
fait sur les zones humides et moi je
vais vous faire une
proposition de visite vous viendrez dans
vos départements le doux
vous viendrez dans mon dépose pourquoi
pas vous viendrez dans mon départ oui
oui vous viendrez dans mon département
le Doubs et vous visiterez et on vous
fera découvrir quelques zones humides
effectivement comme vous le dites c'est
un sujet délicat parce que c'est un
sujet sur lequel il y a des des
oppositions mais là aussi je pense que
par le dialogue c'est pas dire celui
qu'on veut pas mais c'est pas bien
puisque qu'on veut c'est pas bien non
plus je crois que c'est pas le c'est pas
c'est pas trop le sujet mais voir ce
qu'a fait les pages au-doux Outlook
alors déjà pour arriver à les pages aux
doutes il y avait un syndicat mix sur la
basse loup
j'ai mis au moins 10 ans au conseil
départemental pour expliquer qu'il en
fallait aussi en outlook
on a réussi alors on avait fait chacun
deux syndicats dans un coin on a réussi
à un moment donné pas moi c'est le
nouveau président du conseil
départemental aller regroupé et puis
maintenant on a créé un des pages et sur
un secteur un assez large et je dis pas
que tout va très très bien mais
ça va mieux donc l'occasion
si vous avez un déplacement dans le
département du Doubs ce serait grand
plaisir que le président Philippe alpy
vous fera découvrir ce qui a été fait
sur ce secteur merci à bientôt